this is audible
brilliance audio presents how to be
better at almost everything by pat flynn
performed by the author
this book is dedicated to my grandfather
jon jones and my grandmother jacqueline
jones aka ddop and ddom
introduction why skill stacking is
greater than specialization
you don't have to be the best in the
world to get ahead you don't need to be
number one to see the limelight strike
it rich or find meaning in life you only
need to be good or great or at least
fairly competent at a few things and
then combine those things to foster that
uttermost creative quality within
yourself
specialization a goal that has been
instilled into most of us from an early
age is a snare that has entrapped people
for long enough this book is about to
put an end to that
i don't intend to teach you step by step
some new way of starting a business i
want to teach you one step at a time
a new way of learning and acquiring
skills that you can use if you so choose
to start a business and thus give you a
much better chance of not finding but
creating success
people can take businesses away from you
and so can a bad economy but no one can
rob you of skills unless they rob you of
life which just wouldn't be very nice
you don't need to be born with special
dna for this book to work you only need
to be willing to learn
if you're looking for a mega
inspirational story you won't find that
in much of what i'm about to tell you
but if you'd like to read about a person
who came to earth without any special
inborn ability someone who overcame a
lifelong battle with neuroses and went
on to acquire skills anyway someone who
turned sharply away from the
conventional trajectory in life toward
building a line of successful businesses
becoming a writer a musician a black
belt a b level fitness celebrity and a
whole lot of other seemingly unrelated
but pretty cool things that all merge
dynamically into one another then you'll
probably want to read this
this book is about generalism our goal
is to become better than most people at
most things even if we aren't the best
at any one skill
why do we want to do this
well the first thing i would say is that
at the very least being a generalist
makes you a lot less boring to be around
to be great at many things is frankly a
quality that very few people have most
people are somewhat okay at one or two
things and then either completely
incompetent or downright terrible at
everything else
they typically can't even do simple
things like keeping a house plan alive
not that i would know myself how
difficult that is since the only plan i
ever owned was stolen by my college
roommate who thought it was marijuana of
some kind
only the joke was on him because that's
not what it was it was just a totally
regular plant that my mom got me and i
knew my roommate was the person who
stole it because one day it just
magically appeared on his side of the
room would you look at that i thought i
wonder what's going on here so i said yo
dude did you steal my plan or what and
he told me to relax i was like whatever
man that plan isn't what you think and
then i got over it because that's how
life is you get over things lesson
number one
second if you have any interest in
running or starting a business then
being able to stack a variety of skills
is a thousand times more powerful than
trying to be the best at just one
we call this skill stacking combining
skills in a unique and useful way which
gives you more breadth and versatility
than someone who specializes in one
thing this is something i plan to teach
a lot about so please make yourself
comfortable
finally because happiness as the
philosophers will tell us philosophers
like aristotle and thomas aquinas anyway
i'm not talking about the hedonists here
involves engaging in and enjoying a
genuinely good activity it seems our
fulfillment is not found in what we
accumulate but rather in what we
endeavor to do in other words skills are
good because they give us something good
to engage in and we all need that
so to put it all together this book is
about becoming good or great at many
things and at least fairly competent at
almost everything else and then learning
to combine abilities to form competitive
advantages while at the same time
finding total and complete fulfillment
in life not too heavy enough assignment
right the secret to all of it skill
stacking hey the enemy specialization
ooh
mostly i want to teach you how to get
better at getting better at things the
skill of acquiring skill so you can
build a reputation and a thriving
business if you so choose with all the
skills you never had and never thought
you needed to have the problem as i see
it is that since most self-help books
these days are about topics like finding
confidence when you're semi overweight
or marketing yourself on social media
nobody's thought to teach you these
inclusive skills and while i'm all for
finding confidence when you're semi
overweight i used to be one such person
we'll talk about that in a bit and
marketing yourself on social media those
types of skills have little to do with
being happy and successful on the most
fundamental level
happiness is a skill business is a skill
i'm going to teach you how to get the
skills you need
and then how to combine those skills to
find your competitive streak and
creative spirit am i a super creative
person well i should like to think that
i'm at least somewhat creative i draw
things i record music and i write i even
entered a video game tournament once i
didn't do half bad i won the first round
anyway
but the reason i'm creative if i'm
creative at all is that i'm a generalist
i'm somebody who got good at many things
and then found a way to pull them
together to come up with ideas for
and this always sounds somewhat
self-aggrandizing when i say it like
this making money and more important
having a pretty fun time doing it i only
say pretty fun because there were one or
two times it didn't go quite as well as
i had hoped i'll get over it you know
what it is hard being me thank you for
saying that no really it means more than
you know here let's sit and maintain eye
contact
so this is the way this book will work
first i like number anything keeps me
organized i'll talk about generalism and
the principles behind it and why i think
this philosophy can help you or anyone
find success and happiness by doing the
things you love and making money from
them doesn't that sound nice i think
that sounds nice
second i'll talk about skill stacking
and why it's more effective for being an
entrepreneur and human and
specialization we're trying to be the
best at just one thing third i'll talk
about how to get better at anything that
interests you for a series of principles
that makes learning new skills 40
million times easier i'll also share
with you the skills i think almost every
person needs to get started getting
ahead both financially and figuratively
and don't worry it's not like any of
these skills take all that long to
develop it's just that most people never
think to develop them finally we'll talk
about how to actually build a skill
stack and put all your new found talents
to work in attaining the good life ah
yes the good life because it wouldn't be
a self-help book without talking about
that
along the way we'll discuss some
well-known people who use this
philosophy of generalism case studies
you could say of those who became good
or great at many things to find success
and meaning and fulfillment
you'll also find more of these
additional opportunities to see
generalism in action in the appendix
people like george washington carver
whom i did a book report on in the third
grade just so you know a little about my
credentials for example george
washington carver was more than just an
innovator with the peanut and the sweet
potato he was also known for his
advocacy of a proper understanding of
the relationship between faith and
science in addition he was a strong
original proponent of environmentalism
while at the same time offering advice
to business leaders and establishing
outreach programs the man did a lot
because he was capable of a lot and he
had a huge heart he was even a competent
painter i'll also mention several
contemporary figures along the way which
is my way of saying people who aren't
quite so well dead
as i said my goal isn't to teach you
step by step some new way of starting a
business because that i think would be
boring my goal is to teach you principle
by principle how to become better at
almost everything and then help you
figure out what skills you may need to
do all the things you want in life
i get that this book may be saying some
peculiar things and that you probably
think i'm somewhat peculiar as well but
trust me when i say i'm on to something
and that specialization is not the way
to go in life so many people are still
so preoccupied with trying to become the
best at just one thing but the greatest
opportunities present themselves to
those who are preoccupied
not with excelling at one skill but with
being just good enough at the right
combination of abilities perhaps the
greatest feature of generalism is that
you don't need to have any sort of
genetic head start you don't need a
perfectly groomed set of eyebrows or a
strong pair of arms or a fast set of
legs you can just be whoever you are and
that's enough this philosophy is all
very mr rogers and since you're not
trying to be the best in the world at
one particular thing you don't have to
be the best in the world anything you
can just be you and i can just be me and
that's more than adequate because
anybody can get better at almost
everything i'm not saying the world
doesn't need specialists like usain bolt
or michael phelps or whoever designs
microchips for nasa but i am saying i
was never going to be that good and not
to sound insulting i doubt you were
either and that's fine because most
people shouldn't be specialists to begin
with that's why we have generalism
it's not that specialization is
unimportant it's just that so many
people think that it's way more
important than it is or that
specializing is the only way to get
ahead in life when they'd be better off
focusing on breadth as much as depth of
skill
generalism allows people the freedom to
become moderately skilled at a number of
different things and then to put these
skills on top of each other to sneak
ahead because the competition god bless
them never thought the game could be
played in such a way
so that's what we're going to do if
you're reading this book you may already
know a little bit about me or maybe you
don't but that's where i'm going to
start because believe it or not i know a
lot about me and you'll see a lot of it
is going to apply to you
chapter 1 when great is the enemy of
good
it's not like the idea of generalism
just occurred to me something i had to
figure out after going on a long time in
the opposite direction like many of us
when i was a kid i thought i should grow
up to be the best at something and for
me that something was the guitar
i wanted to be the fastest and most
virtuosic guitarist around so i could
become famous get tattoos and do drugs
and all that obviously this isn't how
things turned out here's why first i
have maintained a healthy paranoia
regarding substance abuse because with a
family history of addiction problems i
know very well what i might end up like
i also maintain an unhealthy fear of
needles in general and have way too much
of an indecision problem to settle on
something as permanent as a tattoo
plus i don't care all that much about
becoming famous anymore for reasons
we'll later get into those um lofty
goals aside
i realized about five years into playing
guitar the specialization wasn't getting
me to the places i wanted to go
by the time i was in high school i was
in my opinion the best guitarist around
but only a few people enjoyed hearing me
play since i only played stuff that
other guitarists wanted to listen to
like sweet picking guitar solos for
non-musicians an example of sweet
picking can be heard quite prominently
throughout the work of virtuoso
guitarists from the 1980s like invade
malmsteen check out arpeggios from hell
because and this is something every
specialist eventually realizes there
comes a point in every skill when you
become so good you suddenly lose people
on a common level and begin appealing
only to other specialists and that's
when you know you've gone too far
most people in my high school didn't
want to hear virtuosic guitar solos they
just wanted to be asked to prom by some
singer-songwriter kid with a dave
matthews haircut so it would have been
better if i hadn't spent so much time
perfecting sweep picking and instead had
gotten just a little better at singing
this was a clear case of where a skill
stack singing and playing the guitar was
more attractive than specialization
being a solo guitarist because if the
goal was to get attention as a person
slash musician it was the generalist in
my case my friend tom who was doing so
and not the specialist me who might
every once in a while impress people
with a fiery guitar solo but could not
write a catchy melody and since most
people are basically philistines when it
comes to this stuff they don't care for
all that technical mumbo-jumbo they just
want a tune they can come along to
that was lesson number one in which
somebody who was not as good at the
guitar as me was getting the thing that
i wanted out of being a guitarist which
was having people say how good a
guitarist he was when everybody should
have been saying how good a guitar
player i was
but how would they know that since none
of them were musicians as you can
imagine all this made me somewhat
displeased
so specialists mostly appeal to other
specialists i got it then
but this was also not the only case
where i was the person who was better at
something yet not doing quite as well on
the let's call it commercial level
yes i was in my opinion the best
guitarist in my high school but that
hardly says anything since there were
only about 10 kids in my high school who
even played the guitar to begin with
it's not like i had all that much
competition living in rural wisconsin
it wasn't until i began auditioning for
college that i realized how ordinary my
abilities were even as a so-called
specialist this was lesson number two
not only had specialization not gotten
me to where i wanted to be in life
but even with practicing seven hours a
day i still sucked i didn't suck suck i
just sucked in the sense like wow really
all these years and i'm still not even
close to being nearly as good as i
thought that's a bummer
because there i was practicing every
waking moment on that bastard of an
instrument and i got my ass handed to me
by some 12 year old korean kid in an
audition for berkeley that literally
happened
so lesson number three was waking up to
the grim reality of diminished returns
and how little i got back for every
additional hour i dedicated to getting
better at the guitar when i could have
gotten so much more in return if i'd
merely invested that time in other
skills like singing songwriting or
producing
i still would have gotten shown up on a
technical level by that kid at berkeley
but that was going to happen anyway even
if i decided to increase my practice by
seven more hours per day i seriously
doubt i would ever have gotten to be as
good as he was maybe he simply had
connections in his brain that never
formed for me because he started playing
guitar when he was two but i didn't get
started until i was in the eighth grade
or maybe he was just smarter than me
that is also possible
one problem with specialization is that
success is too often dependent on
factors beyond your control like who
your parents were where you were born
how you were raised what you look like
and so on the good news is that
generalism doesn't rely on any of that
so it doesn't matter if your parents
were models or meth addicts and it
doesn't matter if you have any skill at
all you can be a total loser and still
succeed i did
but if i'm going to import to you any
wisdom at all it's probably best to tell
you a little bit about my own journey
from being a specialist and not
succeeding to becoming a generalist and
doing fairly well for myself all things
considered as you probably gathered and
will return to it i started out wanting
to be a guitar player i practiced my
calluses off striving to become the best
guitarist in the world even though i now
know that was never going to happen but
the things i learned by acquiring that
skill have been super important and
eventually helped me become a writer
business owner and entrepreneur
now since we're already such good
friends i'll let you in on this sometime
around the ninth grade my buddies asked
me to participate in a wet t-shirt
contest to see who had the bigger man
boobs me or my friend sean
i'm sorry to have to report this but it
was about the only competition i won in
high school though the upside was that
it inspired me to start getting in shape
so after being humiliated in front of
everyone whose opinion i cared about i
began reading a bunch of books on
dieting and exercise and eventually i
signed up for taekwondo where i got into
strength training in kettlebells what
are kettlebells they're a form of
weights that sort of look like cannibals
with a handle on them don't worry about
that now we'll come back to it
in the meantime i experienced a lot of
panic attacks and went through a period
of agoraphobia where i felt like i
couldn't leave my house without a
chaperone and a lucky charm of some kind
i'm not going to sugarcoat this life
pretty much sucked at this point and
that's probably where i bottomed out
high school was tough for a lot of kids
right
through taekwondo i learned about
meditation and started to get a hold of
myself in 2006 or 2007 while i was still
in high school i decided to start a
youtube channel and a blog to talk about
getting in shape and lifting weights and
meditation and pretty much everything
else i was interested in i wanted to
help others because i was starting to
feel a lot of the benefits from
consistently working out and my life was
changing in some positive ways
i was thrilled to be accepted into
school for music except my grandmother
isn't that a grandmother's job talked me
into getting a real degree in economics
and finance but i continued to blog and
i put up a lot of information about
exercise and my personal struggles with
weight and anxiety
people responded to that and saw me as
someone to whom they could relate
someone they said who is often helpful
and sometimes funny
and about my second year in i realized i
could maybe do this for a living that is
fitness at first i was doubtful because
i thought back to how i never made it as
a guitarist even though i practiced more
than anyone or so i thought and i looked
at my fitness levels and admitted i was
nowhere near the most in-shape person in
the world i realized i was never going
to be the strongest or the biggest or
the best at anything but i knew i could
become fit in a very general way lean
and strong and muscular and flexible i
could balance on my hands and do muscle
ups and lift heavy things and that
impressed people they saw that i was
good at many things and they wanted to
know how i did it
also because i wasn't specializing i
didn't get hurt as much as everyone else
the friends who were bodybuilding or
powerlifting and driving themselves to
the breaking point in the training would
get injured and lose interest so there i
was also writing my blog and making
videos for youtube meditating a lot and
practicing taekwondo it was really
centering me people also began
complimenting me on my writing so i took
that as an invitation to study writing
more deeply and to learn how to become a
good communicator and craft prose in a
way that is casual and accessible people
were following my blog they said not
only to learn about generalism and
fitness but to enjoy my storytelling and
all the outrageous things i had to say
so that was neat
this was an epiphany of sorts though a
very gradual one whereby i began to see
the value in a skill stack in which the
combination of my fitness abilities and
my writing skills even though i was far
from being the best at either seemed to
be intriguing when put together it was
like a sandwich even if all the
ingredients aren't amazing themselves
they still taste pretty good when mushed
together eventually i realized that i
never needed to specialize
i never needed to be the best piece of
pastrami i just needed to be good enough
pastrami and then have some bread and
sauerkraut and creamy enough dressing i
also had no direct competition because
most of the people i was up against in
the fitness industry weren't writers
and most writers weren't in the fitness
industry
come my senior year of college i fell
into my first big book deal because one
of my followers was looking for someone
to write a book about fitness i got the
deal and even did a pretty darn good job
with that book or so the publisher said
so it led to a series
and along the way i learned a lot about
marketing and business and sales i
learned about psychology and philosophy
as well and i studied all of it with a
furious interest so i could start to
make a living based on everything i was
doing
up until that point i had done a fine
job at getting attention but almost
nothing to make money from it i began to
spend a lot of time with business
mentors and i went to conferences to
have my mind exploded by people who made
more money than i even knew existed and
all that added to my skill stack by the
way
so back to my grandmother's advice or
not as the case may be
while this was happening i was still in
school studying economics and finance i
said to my advisor hey listen so i've
got these books i have to write and i'm
running a business and i was just
wondering if instead of taking that last
free elective i could have a couple of
life credits let's call them well long
story just a little less long he had no
idea what i was talking about and i
eventually dropped out
and that too became part of my message
because as my business grew people began
asking me where i went to school
assuming i must have degrees in all of
this but i relished showing that college
is not necessary to be successful
education is a good thing but you can
get that from books and coaches and
mentors the funny thing however is that
i have been offered the opportunity to
go back to school for philosophy which
i'm now working on because one of my
followers happens to be a professor at
this most adorable little university and
he's hoping i'll have a better
experience as a grad student okay sure
why not we'll see how that goes the
point of this is that eventually you do
indeed become the person you want to be
even if you don't think it's in the way
that you want you become somebody who is
successful and productive and useful but
not by being the best you hope to be
in my case with the guitar you become a
generalist and that's how it happens
it's the accumulation of all these
different skills that sets you apart
it's how you manage to weave them all
together in a at first haphazardly but
eventually deliberate way that makes
your existence enchanted
lessons you learn in one area apply to
what you're doing in another area and
the other way around and no skill you
ever learn remains completely unused
everything is connected and everything
comes into play eventually
so don't throw anything away because
good things are going to come from
everything you're doing or will be doing
your skills may all very soon coalesce
and you'll have money and c-level fame
but here's the thing i want to leave you
with
if you're not something without the sea
level fame then you're not something
with the sea level fame no amount of
commercial success is ever going to make
you happy
the last set of skills we need to talk
about here are character traits because
self-improvement isn't about getting
things it's about becoming someone and
the someone worth becoming is a person
who cares about not what they get but
rather what they create the getting
should be just a byproduct of doing
decent work your concern should be
focused on whether you're putting things
into the world that people benefit from
and enjoy using and another concern
should be whether people like being
around you so it's not just about what
you create but also the kind of person
you are because of what you create
for now all i want you to know is that
everything works out okay in the end
well at least it has so far for me life
is hard writing is hard everything is
hard but eventually you find meaning in
all of what you do because you discover
that happiness is found by engaging in
good activities and that's what being a
generalist is it brought me to where i
am today which is a lot better than
where i was a decade ago now you know a
little bit about my autobiography though
trust me you'll find out a lot more
let's talk a bit about freedom
chapter 2 gaining your freedom for
excellence and the right to choose
wrongly if necessary
in late high school and early college i
went through something of a libertarian
phase where i became super skeptical
about everything essentially i was snake
from escape from new york whose answer
to all the world's problems was listen
fella i don't give a [ __ ] about your war
or your president this isn't the most
productive attitude a person can have
but i did get at least one thing out of
it which was an appreciation for human
freedom but as i became older and
hopefully wiser and came to see the good
in people i realized there was this
whole other kind of freedom i hadn't
previously appreciated
the libertarian cares about people's
ability to do what they want without
interference from some tyrant or some
other power that's called freedom of
indifference or autonomous
self-direction if you like but the other
kind of freedom the freedom that's
particular to generalism is the freedom
of self-expression and that's just the
ability to do things because you've
gained the ability to do them
the libertarian is right to say that
freedom of indifference is important
because yeah you shouldn't enslave
people that's not a good thing slavery
bad everyone agree but at the same time
the libertarian is incorrect to think
that freedom of indifference is all
people need for a happy life because
there's really no assurance that just
because people are free will make the
most of themselves obviously we can see
this because we live in a country with
large amounts of freedom and yet large
numbers of people feel their lives
haven't amounted to much of anything
thus it seems that freedom of
indifference is necessary but is not in
itself a sufficient means for happiness
obviously we need the ability to make
decisions for ourselves in order to make
the right decisions for ourselves but
just because we have the ability to make
our own decisions doesn't mean we will
make the right decisions we might make
the wrong decisions for ourselves so
that's not good
i don't want to make a philosophical
treatise of this but ultimately here's
what i'm trying to say
there's this second kind of freedom
outside freedom of indifference that is
more essentially tied to happiness and
that freedom is called freedom for
excellence
the secret to finding freedom for
excellence comes from living life in a
way that does not center around simply
doing whatever you want if i were to put
it more bluntly i would say freedom for
excellence is more about fighting
tyrants from within
and freedom of indifference is more
about fighting tyrants from without
for example i'm only free to express
myself as a musician after i develop my
abilities on a musical instrument but i
can't develop those abilities unless i'm
determined to follow a set of rules and
practice habits it's only by limiting my
freedom in one sense that i can enhance
it in another it's only by giving up the
freedom to not practice the guitar or
practice the guitar however i please
that i can practice the guitar in a way
that's effective which eventually grants
me the freedom to express myself through
the instrument
this is freedom of indifference you
don't tell me what to do i won't tell
you what to do and we'll all just get
along again there's something to this
it's the stuff all good constitutions
are made up but then there's this other
kind of freedom that says hey look man
it's great you don't want to be
anybody's personal minion i'm with you
there but do you really think just doing
whatever you want is going to lead to a
happy existence
actually dude this is what i would tell
that person
it's often better to take options away
so long as you're removing those options
yourself
because here is freedom for excellence
this is the freedom that comes from
restriction
freedom for excellence isn't about being
able to move in this or that direction
like the notion of autonomous
self-direction
it's about having the power to pursue
whatever skills you think are worth
having in developing the discipline to
say no to all the things that are
distracting you from your life's purpose
it's about making the decisions that any
perfectly rational person with all
available information about future
outcomes would make which is impossible
since none of us are that rational and
none of us can see into the future
but it's still a worthy exercise freedom
for excellence can be thought of as the
discipline of desires to make the good
at first possible and then effortless
and to me that sounds a lot like
somebody who wants to get better at
things the point of having freedom is
not so you can squander it but so you
can make the most of it and yourself
so you're going to have to learn to make
some hard decisions you're going to have
to learn to put off what's easy for
what's important you're going to have to
live as if you are not free as if you
are a slave to good habits and effective
behavior ultimately you're going to have
to learn to impose restrictions and
practice habits so you don't abuse the
freedom god gave you
i'm not saying you can't choose to live
the way you want i'm only saying that
with freedom comes the ability to choose
wrongly and with that comes consequences
you might not be comfortable living with
for the rest of your life if you
continue to gorge and junk food you're
going to wind up 50 pounds overweight
and maybe someday 200 pounds overweight
and you won't be able to get around on
your own two feet
how much freedom will you have then
so you should know that freedom is not
found in unhealthiness only oppression
is but turn that around a minute because
imagine you start working out and
lifting weights and getting in shape
imagine you work up the ability to do
push-ups pull-ups and handstands and
instead of teasing you people admire
what you can do because that's a certain
kind of freedom too
it's just not the kind of freedom people
think of but it is the kind of freedom
that people want even if they don't
always consider it people want the
ability to do things and the freedom to
express themselves but how are you going
to express yourself through abilities
you don't have
for example you're free to play the
guitar when you learn your scales and
modes and chords just like you're free
to speak french when you've studied the
pronunciation and grammar of the
language you're free to do pull-ups only
after you become more fit and gain
strength all of which comes from
discipline this is freedom for
excellence freedom of indifference is
the freedom to choose otherwise
maybe you grew up getting pretty much
everything you wanted and were allowed
whatever you wanted and you took that
freedom for granted and if you take
freedom of indifference for granted why
on earth would you give any thought to
freedom for excellence
isn't that how it always seems to go
it's not until you're at the point of
losing something forever that you
suddenly beg and plead and make whatever
bargain you can to hold on to it
think about what happens if you let time
slip away and take for granted all this
freedom but don't do a single damn thing
about it think about how much freedom
you have but also how much you don't
have because you aren't getting better
at anything think of all the freedom
that's left on the table so to speak
all of us have a certain amount of
freedom given to us freedom of
indifference which is mostly luck of the
draw but so much more freedom is
available to us freedom for excellence
which is earned if we're willing to
apply just a bit of consistency and
effort
to bring it all together i would say
again that freedom of indifference is a
necessary but not sufficient means for
freedom for excellence and that every
government should secure for its people
that first freedom so they can attain
some of the second on the other hand no
government has any business getting into
our lives and telling us how to be happy
because no government could ever
possibly know what happiness for all of
its citizens is that's really something
for enlightened philosophers like the
author of this book to figure out all of
this of course is building to a much
bigger point which is how becoming a
generalist can make us not just
successful but happy
i believe we all have every right to
pursue happiness but we have no right to
expect happiness just because we live
and breathe
because happiness is not something
somebody can give us and that includes
our parents our spouse and the president
happiness is what happens when we engage
in good activities so happiness is not
only a habit but an act happiness is not
an outcome it's a deed
it's not like we do one thing like get
married or make a million bucks and
suddenly we're happy and that's it
that's not what happiness is happiness
is a state of mind that's produced over
time by doing good things aristotle said
the point of humans is to know things
make things and do things he said that
because humans are rational animals
their goal in life is to seek the good
and the good according to aristotle is
anything that is spiritually physically
or mentally productive without getting
too far ahead of ourselves aristotle and
later on thomas aquinas said the highest
good is god but there are also plenty of
other things on the way to god like art
and engineering and pretty much
everything god made and wanted us to
engage in
this is where becoming a generalist is
important because if happiness is
knowing and making and doing good things
then it certainly stands to reason that
we can increase our happiness by
engaging in many activities not just one
and here it's important to note that our
engagement in genuinely good activities
is not just about the accomplishment of
the activity itself but also about the
kind of character we develop because of
the things we're involved in and the
reasons why in other words by doing good
things and importantly doing them for
the right reasons we become genuinely
good people
the reason i'm spending so much time
laying out the philosophy of happiness
is that before we get into any deeper
principles of generalism we need
something to orient us so that we
actually get better at the things that
are worth getting better at for reasons
that align with finding happiness you
mustn't fall into the trap of pursuing
things only because you're a
megalomaniac
all of us are at risk of becoming
megalomaniacs if we're not careful
if you do so no matter how many things
you get better at you'll always be sour
and resentful and never feel fulfilled
you'll become that person with a monocle
and a cigar who is incessantly on a
quest for power and never satisfied and
always finding someone to blame for his
inadequacies i call this person charles
charles is the opposite of brett a guy
with a skull and an eye patch who lives
out of his suv
as far as we can help it we want to
avoid becoming either charles or brett
charles applies discipline but in the
wrong direction brett does only the
minimum he needs to get by
both are missing out on the meaning of
life
obviously a big part of this book is
about making money doing what you love
and improving the skills you need to
make that happen but there's also no
reason why this can and shouldn't itself
be a genuinely good activity that both
pays the bills and fills you with a
sense of meaning
for something to be a genuinely good
activity it not only has to have
beneficial effects but also has to be
done with good intentions so you have to
do things that help people or at least
not hurt them and you also have to do
these things because you want people to
enjoy what you create even though the
goal is to make a nice little profit
along the way it's the orientation that
will determine whether the objective is
fulfilling the point is that none of
these things need to be mutually
exclusive but unfortunately many people
sacrifice one thing happiness for
another money when all they need to do
to have both is stop being a charles
you can make great money with the right
intentions doing what you love but you
can also make great money with the wrong
intentions doing what you hate
so here's why generalism is important
generalists are people who want to get
better at almost everything because
almost everything is of interest to them
or useful in some way
specialists on the other hand can't help
but match their identity to an outcome
because when people are striving to be
the best in the world they've really put
themselves in a tough situation
they've built unhappiness into the
system whereas generalists are not
overly concerned with an outcome and
enjoy engaging in and getting better at
some genuinely good activity
of course generalists are still going to
dominate the competition because that's
more a happy byproduct of being unique
and good at many things
generalists however never tie happiness
to how many people they are doing better
than because generalists aren't trying
to be better than anyone they're only
trying to be better at things see the
difference
by its very nature specialization is set
up to produce unhappiness either because
you're striving to be the best and not
succeeding at it or because even on the
point zero zero zero one percent chance
that you do become the best it's next to
impossible to stay there eventually
you're going to lose and somebody is
going to take your place and say you
were never the best to begin with they
were i don't know about you but i've
been in a few situations where both of
these things have happened and never did
i feel particularly keen about it when i
specialized in guitar i was always
comparing myself to others and feeling
awful and inadequate and then as soon as
i felt i was doing something special
somebody would swoop in and be like nah
dude you suck here let me show you how
that should actually be played but as a
generalist i don't have that problem
anymore i've gotten away from wanting to
be better than other people and now i
just focus on being good myself
chapter 3 becoming an expert generalist
five key principles
so far we've talked a lot about why
specialization is often a snare and what
to do about it and hopefully you're
starting to see some of the advantages
of becoming a generalist such as being
successful without hating every step
along the way or having any special
inheritance genetic or otherwise often
people pick up a self-help book looking
for tactics or strategies just tell me
what to do so i can get on my way i've
got a meeting to attend but to me that
is totally the wrong way to go about it
what people need first is a foundational
understanding of a general concept
before getting into any of the finer
details for example when it comes to
weight loss one of the principles is
caloric control
often people are concerned with specific
diet plans though and since they don't
understand that any diet plan can work
so long as it reduces calories they wind
up hopping from one diet plan to the
next never knowing why all of them fail
but the reason plans fail or work
initially and then stop working is that
the dieter hasn't understood the theory
of thermodynamics or how metabolism
works once you understand those theories
you can then figure out the most
appropriate diet plan by determining
which one is going to most effectively
get your calories to where they need to
be while taking metabolic adaptations
into account fasting not eating for a
while is one good example it's a topic
i've written a lot about some people
think it's the greatest thing on earth
which sometimes confuses me indeed
fasting works for a lot of people but
it's important to know that it works
because it takes large swaths of
calories out of a person's diet
sometimes fasting doesn't work though
because it makes people so hungry that
they wind up binging on foods they
otherwise would have declined and then
they'll come to me and say hey so i
tried your stupid fasting plan and it
caused me to gain 10 pounds so what
gives wtf
which is when i'll tell them as
delicately as i can
that they should have taken the time to
read the principles section before they
got started with the plan that way they
would have known to modify the fasting
schedule so they wouldn't get to such a
point of overwhelming hunger this is
true for generalism because as we
continue to work through this book we're
going to present a framework that shows
you how you can go about developing
skills before we do so however we need
to understand the principles of what
we're talking about the principles of
getting better at getting better at
things these principles are as follows
one
skill stacking is greater than
specialization
two
short term specialization
three the rule of eighty percent
four integration over
isolation five repetition and resistance
let me give you a brief explanation of
each principle and then we'll see how
they would apply toward getting better
at something probably all of us are
interested in
fitness
skill stacking is greater than
specialization
simply put it's better to be better than
most people at most things than to be
the best at any one thing skills in
combination are more powerful than
individual skills by themselves even if
they aren't as fully developed this is
the fundamental advantage of being a
generalist but it's not enough to
acquire skills you must also learn to
combine them for reference i'm using the
greater than sign to mean better than
short-term specialization
being a journalist doesn't mean you try
to improve at everything at once good
generalists are really just short-term
specialists in the sense that they focus
on one or two things at a time and once
those things are developed up to eighty
percent but never beyond see the next
principle they then turn their attention
to something else
the rule of eighty percent
the rule of eighty percent says that if
one 100 is the best in the world then
never go beyond 80 at anything because
that's specialization territory 80
believe me is still masterful so you can
safely assume that if you're 80 good at
something and still not getting ahead in
life then that something is not your
problem it's time to acquire another
skill
integration over isolation
this principle states that you should
practice only the things you need to get
good at as they pertain to the task at
hand this may seem obvious but often
people focus too much attention on
techniques or skills that make no sense
for what they want to achieve
for example there's no point in a
guitarist who wants to play ac dc songs
learning a b flat 13 chord since ac dc
never uses b flat 13 chords
this principle also states that as far
as possible any technique should be
practiced in the context of whatever
outcome you're hoping to get again
thinking of the guitarist who wants to
play ac dc songs that guitarist should
learn just the chords needed to play
those songs and preferably in the
context of the song itself
specific practice produces specific
results so practice only the things you
need and nothing more
repetition and resistance
finally if you want to get better at
something you need to not only practice
that something but also find ways to
make it harder on yourself it's not
enough to simply do something you also
need to make that something difficult
for yourself
fitness as a metaphor i think one of the
best ways to explain these five
principles would be through the example
of fitness and even though not many
people think of fitness as a skill
they most definitely should because what
is a skill if not the ability to
complete a task and what is fitness if
not exactly that it seems to me that
being able to do a pull-up is hardly any
different in theory from being able to
play a guitar solo since both activities
require the use of repetition and
resistance the only actual difference is
the kind of skill a person is performing
neither activity is any less of a skill
part of the reason a lot of people never
reach their fitness goals is that they
don't think of fitness as a skill they
think of fitness as a habit and while
building a habit is important for
building a skill it's not enough to just
get into the routine of doing something
without also finding a way to progress
within that routine
putting yourself in a routine will make
you marginally better at that skill it
will make you better than people who
don't do that something at all but it
will hardly make you great at it for
that you need these other principles
so how about i talk you through this
from the standpoint of a gym instructor
because wouldn't that be fun who imagine
i'm addressing a bunch of mealy mouth
middle schoolers who are timid about
exercise
essentially my former self
i want to do this because i feel like
when i was in school i got the worst
impression about fitness imaginable
since i was always forced to do it
without understanding why and then i'd
get embarrassed because of how terrible
i was i'm sure some of you can relate
now let me grab my whistle and put my
gym shorts on ready
all right children gather round today is
your first day of gym class so there are
a few things we need to get across
before we subject your tiny bodies to
the rigors that await first it's
important to understand that fitness is
no different than music or math in a
sense that all we're doing is learning a
skill but instead of keeping time or
adding integers we're practicing
physical things like push-ups and
pull-ups and while some people may be
more inclined to be musicians or
mathematicians others may be more
inclined to do pull-ups that doesn't
mean however that people who aren't
inclined to do pull-ups can never be
good at pull-ups by inclined i mean just
naturally good at something
fitness for example is considered a
skill because you get better at what you
practice this is known as specific
adaptations to impose demands
and it applies to literally everything
you can think of you don't get better at
softball without practicing hitting or
pitching you don't get better at making
burritos without folding tortillas you
don't get better at the guitar without
playing guitar and you don't get better
at push-ups without doing push-ups
fitness is really a collection of skills
now isn't it or at least we think it
should be are people really fit if they
can do a thousand sit-ups but can't run
a mile or climb a rope or do a push-up
it doesn't seem to me like they're fit
at all they've just got one ability that
seems like a specialist or somebody
who's good at one thing but bad at
everything else
this class isn't about building
specialists it's about building
generalists our goal is to create what's
called general physical preparedness
children i want you to be capable of and
ready for almost everything i want you
to be able to climb a rope and run a
mile and lift heavy things i don't want
you to worry about being the best at any
one of these gym class activities we'll
leave that for the specialists our goal
is to get as fit as we can across a very
broad array of activities gpp over spp
is our motto
general physical preparedness over
specific physical preparedness why well
a couple of reasons
first the competitive advantage
surely you will not beat specialists at
their specialty but you will beat them
at most anything that isn't you won't
outlift the power lifter but you should
outrun them and have more flexibility in
speed you won't outrun a triathlete but
you should lift heavier weights and have
more muscle than they do
and so on and so forth your generalism
will give you more advantages so if
there were ever a fitness olympics with
all kinds of different tasks to complete
you might not take first place in any
one event but you might take first place
overall
that's kind of what we're going for but
also this fitness and health are not the
same thing and this is something you
really need to understand as we said
fitness is the ability to complete a
task but health is something like the
ideal interplay between the organs and
bodily systems
the problem with specializing is that
you can actually take fitness to the
point where it destroys your health you
can try so hard to be the best at some
physical thing that you blow out your
back in the process or cause your
kidneys to fail these things do happen
and detriments to health are all too
common a price to pay for wanting to be
the best in the world at something
involving fitness
just think of most football players or
power lifters or gymnasts nobody would
deny that a person must be very fit to
achieve greatness in any one of those
sports but i also doubt anyone would
deny that they take a heavy toll
the football player winds up concussed
and the power lifter winds up in need of
new vertebrae and the gymnast winds up
with seriously deformed elbows this is
the price of specialization there is no
escaping it
but the generalist doesn't have to
suffer any such ills since they don't
care about being the best at anything
the generalist and that's you children
doesn't have to put fitness and health
at odds and in fact does exactly the
opposite whatever we do to increase our
fitness should at least not cause harm
to our health and should preferably
improve it this means that if we are
getting fit in one sense we'd like to
see an increase of health in a similar
sense
fitness is a foundation of health and
health is a foundation of fitness
for example here's a sample plan that
you can use to get started on your
general fitness routine let's begin with
this walk 20 to 60 minutes per day
briskly
also use the following morning recharge
mobility routine two minutes of jumping
rope five minutes of turkish get-ups and
two minutes of hindu push-ups just
repeat those exercises for anywhere
between 10 to 15 minutes
now let's take this day by day
on day one i want you to perform a
pushing exercise and a hinging exercise
once i work through the weekly routine
i'll explain some of the exercise
options
so i want you to do five sets of three
reps at your five rep max
on day one of a pushing and hinging
exercise
on day two
i want you to do a squatting and pulling
exercise
do three sets of eight reps at your 12
rep max after that perform a loaded
carry for three sets by one minute
on day three we'll do interval running
that's where you do a 10 second sprint
followed by a 30 second jog followed by
a one minute brisk walk repeat that
sequence for 15 to 20 minutes
on day four we're back to a pushing and
hinging exercise for three sets of eight
reps at your 12 rep max
on day five or back to a pulling and
squatting exercise
five sets of three reps at your five rep
max
after that we'll go back to the carry
three sets by one minute day six
we're going to do a pushing a pulling a
hinging and a squatting exercise all for
three sets by five reps at your seven
rep max
then on day 7 we'll just do some walking
and mobility to recover now a few notes
you can visit my exercise at
www.chroniclestrength.com to find
tutorials for all these exercises but
here is a sample list to get you started
for pushes you could do military press
bench press dips or push-ups for pulls
you could do pull-ups chin-ups bent over
rows
for hinge you could do dead lifts
single-leg deadlifts hip thrusts or
kettlebell swings for squats you could
do front squats back squats goblet
squats or split squats and for the
loaded carriers you could do farmer walk
overhead walk or rack walk again visit
my website or youtube channel to see
these exercises performed and broken
down
also a few more notes when i say at rep
max i mean to use a weight that you
could lift for no more than the number
prescribed so seven rep max means to use
a weight you could lift for no more than
seven reps on that particular exercise
intensity is paramount be sure you're
going heavy enough
and finally i'll leave you with a few
additional resources
first is intervention by dan john
second is my book which i co-authored
with kellyanne petrucci paleo workouts
for dummies i also have a guide of 101
free kettlebell workouts which you can
get at the website www.101
kettlebellworkouts.com finally head to
my youtube channel at www.youtube.com
backslash user backslash
s-u-p-m-u-h-h-u-m-b-r-u-h
to see all these exercises in action
to be a generalist in fitness is to be
fit at many things not just one so we
can say people are fitness generalists
to the extent they can do many tasks
well even if they can't do any one task
best everyone got that please put that
down in your notes this is the first
principle you see
gpp is greater than spp in other words
skill stacking is greater than
specialization
listen up because this next part is
important since i just made the case for
why we're going to focus on being
generalists and not specialists now i
have to tell you how we're going to go
about it and this part is going to sound
a little ironic at first but i promise
it'll make sense once we get into a
couple of examples
the reason it's going to sound ironic is
this a generalist is really just a
short-term specialist i understand that
i just spent the past 15 minutes arguing
against specialization but what i was
really arguing against was not the use
of specialization but being a specialist
and there is a great deal of difference
between the two the use of
specialization is just focusing on
something to get better at it whereas
being a specialist is a commitment to
becoming the best at something because
you think that's where you're going to
find success or happiness a specialist
is someone who uses long-term
specialization then but a generalist is
someone who uses short-term
specialization here sit up straight and
let me explain
the generalists and this doesn't matter
whether it's in fitness or anything else
doesn't get good at almost everything by
trying to do everything at once that
would be a fool's assumption such an
approach would only dilute effectiveness
and cause a person to go mostly nowhere
instead generalists must learn to surge
and maintain they must learn to push in
one area while not letting everything
else fall completely to shreds this is
your second principle a good generalist
is just a short-term specialist mark it
down
for example if you want to get better at
lifting weights then you should spend a
period doing precisely that and we
should make weightlifting the initial
focus of our programming
that doesn't mean we can't still run or
stretch or practice handstands it only
means we've established a priority it
means that if we are ever caught in a
situation where we only have 15 minutes
to work out we should spend most of that
15 minutes squatting or dead lifting or
whatever every skill is obtained by
practicing that skill specifically so we
use short-term specialization to bring
up whatever skill set we need as
efficiently as possible and once we've
attained a sufficiency at that skill we
can then toss it in maintenance mode and
put our attention on a new skill so
maybe we go from lifting weights four
times a week to lifting weights two
times a week and focus more on running
or gymnastics or what have you these are
just examples to get the principle
across don't worry about the details yet
simply know for now that we must devote
a lot of attention and energy to
whatever we want to get better at but at
the same time we should allocate enough
attention and energy to prevent
everything else from deteriorating
the principle of short-term
specialization also relies on the fact
that no skill is quite as difficult to
preserve as it is to learn in the first
place here's what i mean it takes a lot
more effort to get your deadlift to
double your body weight than it does to
keep it there it also takes a lot more
effort to learn a handstand than it does
to maintain a handstand
some skills are surely more slippery
than others in the sense that they fall
off sooner than you'd like but no skill
takes quite so much effort to maintain
as it does to gain think for example of
riding a bike it takes a while to learn
but hardly any effort to remain fairly
decent at it this is why we put more
attention and energy into building a
skill than into holding on to it that's
how this whole thing works but at the
same time we can't expect a skill to
maintain itself we still need to allot
some amount of practice time to it even
if that amount of time isn't as much as
it was before
if we're looking at our curriculum then
maybe we'll spend a unit on strength and
a unit on conditioning and a unit on
flexibility and a unit on something else
and while each of those units will have
a clear specialization we'll still keep
up with everything we've practiced so
far
we'll still lift in the conditioning
unit and will still stretch in the
strength unit even if that isn't where
we spend most of our time our greatest
focus will be on whatever the theme of
the unit is does that make sense and
have you put it in your notes because
this is a very important principle you
cannot be a good generalist without
knowing what short-term specialization
is and how to rotate periods of emphasis
on each particular skill set
essentially what i'm saying is that if
you took a snapshot of a generalist
training program you might assume that
person is a specialist but when you zoom
out and look at how the plan switches
emphasis over time you'll start to see
what we're really after becoming capable
of and ready for almost everything this
brings us to our next principle the rule
of 80
which states that if 100 is best in the
world at something then you should never
go beyond 80 good at anything this might
sound even more peculiar than the last
principle but again it will make a lot
of sense if you can just sit still and
let me explain it to you i appreciate
your patience i really do you're such
good children and handsome
imagine our goal is to become better
than most people at most things which as
generalists it is
then when i must ask do you think you
will ever need to be more than 80 good
at something the answer is never you
will never need to be more than 80 good
at one skill unless your goal is to
become a specialist which would
obviously defeat the entire purpose of
this conversation so that's reason
number one
reason number two is that 80 good at
something is already so far beyond
masterful it's hard to imagine any
situation where getting better at that
something will contribute significantly
to any goal that isn't lifelong
specialization for example say you want
to be generally physically fit and you
can bench press close to 500 pounds
which is in at least the 80th percentile
of power lifting but you're 50 pounds
overweight
adding more weight to your bench press
is not going to help you achieve the
goal of becoming more generally fit at
this point i think nutrition is your
problem i think it's time to learn
another skill
the rule of 80 is really set up as a
sort of shock proof bs detector in the
sense that it's supposed to help us
figure out what our problem isn't
because the closer you get to that 80
percent mark the more you can be sure
that particular skill isn't your problem
another example is if you can run 50
miles but can't lift your own body
weight up to a pull-up bar at this point
it doesn't seem like cardio is your
problem
lack of strength is your problem
finally i want you to know that 80 is
the cutoff not the goal since most of us
will never need to get anywhere near
that proficient at something to get what
we want or need out of it
most people don't need to get to eighty
percent of the world's heaviest
deadlifts to achieve what they need out
of dead lifting they probably need to
only get to twenty to forty percent all
the rule of eighty percent states is
that we should never go beyond eighty
percent good at something because as
soon as we do we're no longer
generalists did everybody get that great
because now we can talk about our next
principle which is integration over
isolation
this is perhaps the most complicated
principle but also the one most worth
understanding because so many people get
so confused about skill development when
it really doesn't need to be complicated
at all
all integration over isolation says is
that you should practice whatever skills
you want to improve in the context of
whatever goal you want to achieve
take an exercise like the pull-up for
example
this is a skill that can be used to
achieve a variety of goals
you can use the pull-up to build
strength muscle or endurance but how you
practice that technique will determine
the effect for example if i want to use
pull-ups to develop strength then i
should keep my reps low and the weight
high by adding a belt with some plates
attached if i want to use pull-ups to
build muscle then i should do a few more
reps with a little less weight finally
if i want to use pull-ups to increase
endurance i should do as many reps as i
can
now i get that some of you think this
example is absurd because you can't
imagine even doing one pull-up at this
point but let's imagine pull-ups aren't
some insanely difficult thing which they
shouldn't be and won't be once i'm
through with you
the point of integration over isolation
is that to the extent that it is
practical we should practice every skill
and technique within the context of
generating an outcome if we're on a
strength program then we should practice
only the exercises we need to build the
most amount of strength and we should
practice those exercises according to
the sets and reps that will make us
strong there is no use of learning
exercises at this point that don't
directly attribute to our goal even if
those exercises seem interesting for
example in this case there's no reason
we should be spending time learning how
to breaststroke the breaststroke is a
fine exercise and useful for endurance
because swimming is useful for endurance
but we shouldn't spend most of our time
during a strength phase in a swimming
pool geriatric workouts excluded
this would be like learning to draw
cartoons when you want to create
realistic oil paintings of landscapes
integration over isolation forces us to
start with the end in mind and devise a
plan based on what we want to achieve
mostly it helps us focus specifically on
the skills we need to practice to
produce a particular outcome for example
if we want to get better at running then
we should put together a plan that
teaches stride mechanics and features
protocols to increase aerobic capacity
and preferably we should be able to
practice stride mechanics within the
context of those aerobic protocols in
other words we practice the technique of
running within the running program
itself what i'm talking about is being
as efficient as possible and focusing
our attention and effort as specifically
as possible on exactly the things we
need to improve and not wasting any time
on extraneous or irrelevant activity
what is extraneous or relevant activity
simply anything that isn't directly
related to the goal bench press is
extraneous or relevant if the goal is to
become a better runner but it's not
extraneous or relevant if the goal is to
build a bigger chest or upper body
strength this principle requires context
and just about any skill or technique
can be validated by it so long as you're
clear on what you want to achieve and
what's needed to achieve it
a running program probably shouldn't
focus over much on bench pressing though
we should according to our third
principle and press every now and then
just to maintain what we've already
earned
and probably a strength program
shouldn't focus over much on running so
we should again according to our third
principle run every now and then to
maintain that particular skill over time
we switch back and forth to develop each
of these areas independently this brings
us to our final principle repetition and
resistance we can't expect to get better
at something without doing that
something in finding ways to make it
harder as we go in other words if we
want to get stronger we need to do an
exercise and then add weight keep in
mind adding weight is increasing
resistance it isn't enough to just do
any old exercise however we feel like
doing it
we must do the exercise we want to get
better at and we must find a way to
challenge ourselves with it
let's take the example of push-ups since
i think that's something everybody
should be able to do and if you can't
then here's your opportunity to learn
the first thing you need to understand
is that you're never going to get better
at push-ups unless you actually practice
that repetition and you're never going
to get past a certain point with
push-ups unless you find ways to make
them challenging resistance maybe that
means doing more push-ups in a set
density or more push-ups throughout the
day volume or adding weight to or
changing the angle of your push-ups
intensity or just doing them more often
frequency all these variables are ways
of increasing resistance and all of them
work though some may work better for
certain exercises than others but also
remember that how we challenge ourselves
with push-ups should depend on the
principle that we covered before this
one integration over isolation
so for example if we want to use
push-ups to develop strength we should
focus more on adding intensity
increasing weight or altering the
leverage whereas if we want to use the
push-up to develop endurance we should
focus more on adding density increasing
the number of reps we do per set
again some context is needed but for now
we aren't trying to get that specific i
just want you to understand the
principles and their universality yes
universality because so far i've only
spoken about how these principles apply
to skills found within fitness but
perhaps it would now be appropriate to
take off my gym shorts and provide a few
analogies of how they might apply to
other disciplines except i won't
actually take off my shorts because you
either go commando or you don't and look
i've made my decision at some point
you're going to have to make yours
let's imagine we get better at writing
and we're looking at these five
principles first we need to determine
what kind of writing we want to get
better at do we want to become better
humor writers or fantasy novelists or
what let's say we want to become better
human writers short-term specialization
i think that's a fine place to start and
a useful skill especially if you ever
want to start a blog or write a book
since it's a good thing to be able to
make people laugh
then we've got to think about the skills
we need to get a chuckle out of someone
the first it seems would be the power of
observation since all humor is
essentially just telling people the
truth in a more efficient way than what
they're used to for example i saw a
chuckle-worthy definition the other day
that read charity verb to make an end
great
i thought that was pretty funny because
it's something to which everybody can
relate you probably remember a time when
you opened your house to people and fed
them dinner and let them shower and did
they ever say thanks no all they did was
leave dishes in the sink hair in the
drain then obviously you felt like
asking them to leave but you thought
about what jesus said on the mountain
about people you can't stand so since
you aren't a bible scholar you can't
remember what it was only you're pretty
sure it had something to do with being
nice
so it seems to me that being funny comes
down to surprising people with something
they already think is the case at least
that's part of it so maybe you start
developing your humor by paying better
attention to what's going on and taking
notes of things that seem ironic that's
repetition and resistance and say you're
in the fitness field like i am so maybe
you pay particular attention to whatever
ironies you see in the gym integration
over isolation which god knows offers no
small amount of material
now i don't want to get too far into
this just yet i only want to point out
how these principles apply no matter
what skill you want to get better at and
obviously humor is an example of a skill
that can attach to basically anything so
it fits in perfectly with the idea of a
skill stack
here's how i'd like to wrap this section
up
memorize these five principles and start
to think of ways they might apply to
something you want to get better at or
use these five principles to assess why
you didn't improve at something as
quickly as you would have liked that's
what's helpful about the way we're doing
things you can apply the principles of
generalism to get better quickly and you
can employ them to figure out where or
why you're stuck on something you've
already started
in the next couple of sections i'll
begin to outline what i believe are a
series of essential skills because if
we're going to acquire a skill stack we
need a foundation on which to construct
it and that foundation should be
composed of skills that are useful and
awesome for everybody so go use the
bathroom if you need but hurry back the
fun is just about to begin
chapter 4 how to practice better and
improve faster
now that i've explained the principles
of generalism i'll tell you how i came
to learn about each of them through a
specific skill or teacher
i want you to know before we begin
however that these principles are
universal and not attached to any
particular skill
even if i happen to learn them through
playing guitar growing eggplants or what
have you
there were also times when i already
knew the principles but they hadn't yet
gelled completely in my consciousness
they were merely a blood pudding of
amalgamated ideas that needed more time
to congeal i suspect this might also be
the case for you a lot of these
principles are pretty much common sense
and sometimes people just need to
structure them up or flesh them out or
allow them to marinate my hope with the
sections that follow is to do exactly
that by giving you a fuller
representation of each of these five
principles and some context on how they
apply or at least how they applied for
me
later we'll get specific on how and what
to practice in accordance with these
principles for assembling a skill stack
please understand that these five
principles are the orienting and
philosophic foundation of generalism and
without them any tactics we'll examine
later may still be limitedly useful but
might also send you in the wrong
direction chasing pointless things
principles are what guide us so don't
skip ahead be patient and thorough in
examining these following few pages the
lessons are neither long nor lugubrious
but they are important
principle one skill stacking is greater
than specialization
i learned about skill stacking from my
high school guitar instructor who made
me very unhappy at first because all i
wanted was to learn shredder style
guitar solos but every time i proposed
doing so he'd say we should take the
time to learn other kinds of music too
he'd say he could tell i was very eager
to play shredding solos but that alone
wasn't going to make me a better
musician essentially he taught me that
since i was already good at that type of
solo getting better at that wasn't going
to take me where i wanted to go and he'd
explain how he's kept himself in
business as a guitarist by filling
whatever roles people needed either in a
studio or a band that isn't something a
specialist particularly a shredder style
guitar soloist is able to do
and then to prove the point he'd show
how he could play rock music and jazz
and country and how he could sing and
how he could riff on the piano and the
bass and the drums all hooting and
hollering like and so i came to decide
that maybe this guy was on to something
but that was hardly the half of it
because then he'd show me how adept he
was at producing and marketing as well
since he had 13 albums out and not one
of them was a total flop by any
conventional standards of
self-publication meaning they sold more
than 13 copies
so you'd think at this point i'd have
been receptive to what he had to say but
don't worry i definitely wasn't i was
still stuck on being a specialist the
greatest shredder style guitar soloist
in a time when nobody listened to that
technique but he kept trying to get me
to understand and take his advice to
heart he'd explained that it was because
he was not the best at any one thing
that he always had a paying gig and had
always been able to make money on his
own and support his family
he also explained how getting good at
many different things gave him many
different streams of income including
playing in a band playing in recording
sessions selling his own music and of
course giving guitar lessons to friendly
people like me
this is how he was making half a million
dollars or so a year as a guitarist
without being famous or the best in the
world without even having a college
degree when he told me that i was like
wow this guy makes more money than my
dad and i kid you not he actually said i
bet that's more money than your dad
makes it struck me you know that's kind
of a weird thing to say but technically
i think you're correct
now here was a guy who made good money
and he was doing something i admired he
was playing the guitar he was awesome at
it sure he wasn't famous like angus
young of acdc but he was really good and
he was beholden to no one he made his
own music and his own schedule he was
doing what he loved and thriving while
doing it the secret to all of it skill
stacking
not only did he play a number of diverse
styles and instruments but he took the
time to learn all the necessary business
related skills such as producing and
marketing and sales he was the first to
admit he wasn't the best at any of it
but he didn't need to be just as any
true generalist knows right friends you
only have to be just good enough at the
various necessary skills and then stack
them together in a unique and useful way
my guitar instructor did exactly that
and that's why people chose him when
they needed someone on their recordings
since most bands don't need a musician
who's the best at just one thing they
need somebody who can play rock one day
and jazz and next and maybe even sell
some paraphernalia what i learned from
my guitar instructor is that skill
stacking applies at the bottom level and
the top within a specific skill and to
the whole lasagna of life itself for
instance he could also get the word out
about his skills and what he could offer
and he could cut albums that didn't
sound half bad it were quite catchy in
fact i never appreciated that until i
became older but looking back now i can
see this was all very deliberate and
effective and good
he was a stark contrast to a lot of my
previous guitar teachers yes some were
more skilled guitar soloists or had
better dexterity but they were not as
musically versatile
few knew much about marketing or
producing or sales so maybe that's why
some of them were still living in a
studio above the music shop with their
girlfriends subsidizing the rent they
didn't have the skills to stack so they
were hoping they could become a good
enough specialist to be signed by a
record label
i think that last point is among the
most significant differences between
generalists and specialists specialists
try to be the best at something so they
can get enough attention from somebody
to scoop them up and offer them a
contract of some kind they end up being
dependent on somebody else
generalists however acquire whatever
skills they need so they can be
successful entirely on their own that my
little rabbit is the secret to sweet
sweet freedom
i learned this principle as a young
guitarist but it didn't fully apply
until i was a business owner that's when
it finally became obvious when it comes
to business i'm not the best at any one
facet of it i'm not the best at writing
or sales and i'm not the best at
training employees but i'm good to great
at all of it which is why i've been able
to make money doing what i like really
doing what i love it's only because i've
been able to stack skills that i've
gotten ahead of those who are clearly
more capable than i am at a particular
specialty so what if someone can do more
pull-ups than i can because i can still
do a lot of pull-ups but you want to
know something i can also launch a
successful ad campaign which that person
probably has no idea about and maybe
someone can launch a better advertising
campaign than i can but i'm guessing i'm
in better physical shape see how that
works as a generalist you always win so
long as you know what to compete in
here's the short of it skill stacking
lays a foundation for success it gives
you a chance at a thriving meaningful
productive and independent existence
something like a wakaya alpaca standing
ever so strong and free atop the andes
mountains and fluffy let us not forget
now how you go about stacking those
skills is something we'll get into later
but first let's spend some time on the
next principle which applies more
specifically to skill development
short-term specialization
principle 2 short-term specialization
i finally decided i needed to get a
handle on things when my anxiety became
enormously high i thought it was time to
start meditating i hired an online coach
some zen guy and the first thing he
asked was how often i was practicing
meditation i told him not very often
just a little bit here and there he
asked me how many minutes a day that was
and i said sometimes five minutes and
sometimes zero minutes because i've got
a lot of other things to do he then
asked how much time i put into things
that really mean a lot to me like
exercise and guitar and i said typically
i practice those every day
at that point though i could see what he
was trying to do so i got ahead of him
and said you know coach i think i know
what i need you know what i need coach i
need to start practicing meditation like
i practice the guitar now what do you
think of that coach he said that sounded
infinitely wise and wondered how i ever
came to such an enlightened conclusion
he told me that meditation like any
skill must be owned with focus and
intensity
he said that it would not do to just
meditate whenever the convenience
presented itself just as it would not do
to exercise or play the guitar in such a
haphazard way and expect to get better
at those
that is no way to make progress what you
need to make progress he continued is
consistency yes how much i wanted to get
rid of my anxiety and i said i wanted to
get rid of it more than anything he said
that sounded significant but asked do
you hate it more than anything
even more say than those little tiny
hairs that fall down the back of your
neck when you're getting a haircut i
thought about it and concluded they're
about equal that's how he knew i was
seriously afflicted
he asked why i was prioritizing so many
activities other than getting rid of
anxiety
if anxiety was my biggest concern he
wondered why was i so focused on things
that had no relevance to that i told him
that i didn't know why and he speculated
that perhaps i was afraid of something
he was right i was afraid of what i
might be giving up by getting rid of my
anxiety i admitted i was scared that if
i started to specialize on something
like meditation i would lose progress
elsewhere and not be as good at those
other skills anymore he understood i
told him this in itself gave me anxiety
he seemed almost irritated at that and
he advised me that all progress itself
is a matter of managing compromise and i
shouldn't hold such a childish view of
things if i want to fix one problem i
have to be willing to make a little less
progress on another at least for the
time being he noted that if i'm working
especially hard on getting rid of my
anxiety then i shouldn't be concerned
with setting all-time personal records
in weightlifting or perfecting my
songwriting i should just focus on
getting good at meditating i shouldn't
let other areas of my life fall apart
but i need to be willing to let progress
slide occasionally and become okay with
the notion of opportunity cost
sacrificing some gains in one area for
focus on another i understood what he
was saying but i didn't like it he said
it didn't matter what i liked this is
how we improve and i didn't have to
specialize in meditation forever i only
needed to dedicate a long enough period
of time to make progress and establish a
routine and then i could back off a bit
he explained that meditation is just
like exercise in the sense that i must
devote more effort and energy up front
to overcome my inertia but once i've
built that momentum it becomes fairly
easy to maintain i didn't know it at the
time but this man was explaining the
principle of short-term specialization
to me
the fear i had is the same fear i think
all of us have we make progress in one
area but then we're afraid to switch
focus because we don't want that
progress to taper off we're afraid that
if we focus on adding muscle after
losing weight we won't be as lean as we
were before so we keep ourselves in a
cycle of dieting sure we stay lean but
that comes at a cost we never really
grow or improve in anything else
however if we would have just been okay
with shifting focus for a while we could
have added strength and muscle and so
what if we gain a little weight in the
process
we could always focus on leaning out
again later and when we do we'll look
even better than before since we'll have
a lot more definition in our muscles
it's that little sacrifice in the short
term that allows for considerable
progress in the long term that's
short-term specialization so yeah while
i was meditating i made a lot of
progress reducing my anxiety but not as
much at everything else but i still
maintained everything else and i even
improved upon some skills just because
you switch emphasis doesn't mean you
have to let other skills fade away it's
not actually all that hard to get good
at meditating while doing other things
like staying physically active for
example there's enough time to short
term specialize in each but it is hard
to start a successful business while
training for a bikini competition and
recording a guitar album for instance
these types of goals are better done one
at a time i would think
the point is that you have to be okay
with letting some areas develop more
slowly as you surge in the area you most
want to improve you have to be okay if
progress in some areas slips off a bit
as you're doing this
this all sounds fine in theory but in
practice it comes with a lot of hang-ups
because once we get good at something we
can hardly stand to see it recede even
if only an inch you're going to have to
get over that like i did at some point
these sacrifices have to be made so they
might as well be made intentionally and
remember you're not letting progress
slide forever when you come back to
something later you'll probably make
more progress than ever since you've
given yourself the time to improve in
other areas that might very well support
the previous thing for example say you
got strong at dead lifting but then you
decide to lose some weight so you go on
a diet well chances are while you're
leaning out your deadlift isn't going to
be as strong as it was even though you
should still train the deadlift just
accept that your deadlift will fall off
a little because the sacrifice you're
making with that skill is more than
offset by the progress you're making in
body composition once you've reached
your desired level of slimness you can
focus on deadlifting again and the next
thing you know you'll be stronger than
ever at it this time without being 30
pounds overweight that's the power of
short-term specialization back to my
meditation example after my coach said i
was being silly about this he told me to
start meditating first thing in the
morning and to put my best effort into
it he said to also challenge myself with
one anxiety-producing activity a day and
use mindfulness to see my way through it
see principle number four integration
over isolation i followed his advice and
because i was willing to specialize for
a little while i began to see a
fantastic improvement in my quality of
life i became way less anxious and
started to sleep better and was a lot
nicer to people because of that
obviously this carried over and improved
my performance elsewhere since less
stress meant more attention more focus
in a roundabout way it was specializing
in meditation that made me better at a
lot of other things including working
out because of the carryover benefits
just like the carryover benefits you get
from exercise
not all skills work this way but a lot
of them do it's nice when it happens
speaking of fitness this may be an
appropriate segue into our next
principle the rule of 80
which is perfectly illustrated by the
gym
principle 3 the rule of 80
the rule of 80 was taught to me in the
weight room since my original fitness
coach was also my taekwondo instructor
who knew very well there was little
point in trying to be the best in the
world at exercising everything we did
had to make me better at what i was
trying to be good at which was kicking
and punching things and to do this he
wanted me to improve as many areas of my
fitness as possible without going too
far in any one direction this would lead
me to being well-rounded which also
means i would be better at taekwondo we
spent a lot of time strength training
but we also ran and stretched muscles he
was making me a generalist in fitness
even if i had never thought of it that
way and the one thing i most expressly
remember about training with him was
that good enough was good enough he
never pushed me to have the world's
heaviest front squat he wanted me to
have only a heavy enough front squat to
get what i needed from the exercise in
this case it was a stronger anterior
chain which meant more powerful kicks
and then leave it at that if an exercise
wasn't making me better at everything
else we stopped focusing so much on it
and moved on
well fast forward a little more than a
decade and here we are with the rule of
80
which as mentioned states that a
generalist should go up to but never
beyond 80 good at anything this
principle was again reinforced by my
business partner sam sikdar sam holds a
major in electrical engineering from the
university of pennsylvania and makes his
living owning martial arts studios he's
a proficient generalist and he's also
good with graphs and numbers the reason
i mention that is because sam once said
that the closer you get to 80 good at
something the more the rate of return
diminishes until it's not worth putting
any more effort in unless you're trying
to be the best in the world at that
particular thing he calls this point the
asymptotic trade-off so if you've ever
seen a chart where the slope suddenly
rounds off and starts decreasing at an
increasing rate you have some idea of
what saam's talking about it's a sort of
flattening out point as far as progress
goes
as i explained in the previous chapter
if you're already 80 good at something
and not reaching your goals that
something isn't your problem for example
imagine being 80 good at bench pressing
well i just looked up the world record
drug free bench press which the internet
tells me is 713 pounds
so if 713 pounds is 100
and 80 good at bench pressing is 570
pounds for men
that is way more than any person needs
to get the benefits from bench pressing
believe that i repeat there is no reason
a generalist needs to be more than
eighty percent good at anything there is
no reason a generalist needs to be more
than eighty percent good at anything
there is no reason a generalist needs to
be more than eighty percent good at
anything
now i know i've repeated eighty percent
a bunch of times but i don't want you to
think of this principle as something you
need to measure with exact percentage
points it's more of a perspective than
anything the bottom line is that you
should just enter training for any skill
with the idea that good enough is good
enough and that the closer you get to 80
at that skill the less likely it is that
that skill is contributing to your
overall goal
for example let's say your goal is to
increase general physical preparedness
well then don't spend most of your time
trying to take your bench press from 320
pounds to 350 pounds and miss out on
everything else
let your bench press stay at 320 pounds
and go work on handstands or sprints or
whatever this is not to say you can't
still make improvements to your bench
press but once you've gotten what you
need out of the exercise the focus
should be shifted
i'm saying that the rule of 80 is used
to inform short-term specialization in
other words once you've reached the
point of good enough it's time to switch
it up but how do you know when good
enough is good enough well that depends
on the goal and what you expect to get
out of whatever you're working on but
the general idea is that you'll need
more of the fundamentals and less of the
things that aren't for strength you'll
need more of the big lifts like squats
and deadlifts and fewer of the isolation
exercises and for business you'll need
to know more about sales and less about
web design
isolation exercises can support the big
lifts but not replace them just like a
good-looking website can support an
effective sales process but is by no
means a sufficient substitute this is
where the rule of 80 meets another
concept one that is far more famous but
shouldn't be confused with the principle
we're talking about so they can
certainly go together the 80 20 rule and
what the 80 20 rule says is that 80 of
your results will come from 20 of your
efforts most of the time anyway
so in strength 80 of your progress will
come from twenty percent of your
exercise selection and in business
eighty percent of your profits will come
from twenty percent of your sales
efforts and so on and so forth
the reason for knowing the 80 20 rule is
not to get rid of the stuff that is less
productive but to allocate your time and
effort toward the stuff that is to be
more efficient say for example you know
that deadlifting is one of those vital
few exercises that offers significant
return on investment little hint it is
well that should tell you it's more
worthwhile to develop the deadlift to a
higher percent than another exercise
that isn't as useful such as for example
the hamstring curl what i'm saying is
good enough at the deadlift will be
closer to 80 percent than good enough at
the hamstring curl because the deadlift
is more useful for building strength
than the hamstring curl
let's move on these numbers are getting
to be a bit much and we still have two
more principles to go next we're going
to see how we can better practice our
chosen skills through integration
principle 4 integration over isolation
as anybody who started a business knows
there are a million things you don't
know about starting a business
which can give you a lot to worry about
and not because you didn't just drop out
of college to make all your dreams come
true by starting a blog about how you
got started exercising again no human
could ever be that important
starting a business is overwhelming so
it's hard like really really hard to
decide what the right efforts are
my business coach was always direct
about this and said that when it came to
business there were a few things i
needed to be great at and a lot of
things i needed to be at least okay at
he said the things i needed to be great
at were attracting attention and making
sales and after that i should perhaps
know a little something about management
and taxes and whatnot but he made it
clear that if the goal was to make money
there were a lot of things i could focus
on but only a few things that i should
focus on he said the essential skills of
any business owner come down to getting
attention making sales and retaining
customers he said any skill that doesn't
contribute to any of those can be
initially ignored
this reminded me of when i was a younger
taekwondo student sam told me that while
there are a thousand and one kicks you
need to know only about five to ten to
be a competitor roundhouse back kick
front kick and so on there is no need he
said to put too much effort into flying
sidekicks or tornado rounds because
you'll hardly ever use them at least not
in sparring anyway well it's no
different with music because my guitar
instructor said pretty much the same
thing
don't worry so much about studying all
those obscure jazz chords or exotic
indian scales because most of the stuff
you'll be asked to play will involve a
lot of the same few things in various
forms think of the rolling stones
think of all the blues based rock bands
get the basics down stick to the
fundamentals
the principle of integration over
isolation starts with the end in mind
what is the goal and how are you going
to get there not coincidentally
integration over isolation is a little
bit like the 80 20 rule we just
discussed because this principle is
supposed to help us focus on what's
important
we need to narrow things down so we know
what to practice and how integration
over isolation says practice only the
things that produce an effect necessary
for the achievement of a goal and ignore
whatever doesn't
the principle also states that we should
practice the skill as best as possible
within the context of the goal we want
to achieve meaning that if we want to
play a particular song and we need to
learn a g chord to do that then we
should practice that g chord in the
context of the song we want to learn
that is in relation to the other chords
in the song at the appropriate tempo and
so on
only we may not be able to do that at
first because the song may have a fast
tempo and we may not be familiar with
any of those other chords so we might
have to pull the g chord out of context
and practice it by itself a while which
would indeed be isolation integration
over isolation doesn't mean a practice
should never isolate an element it only
means a practice should isolate only the
specific techniques or skills you need
that will later become integrated toward
the achievement of the goal
in fact we often will have to isolate
because the skill or technique is new to
us and putting it into context right
away just won't be feasible so we have
to extract that skill or technique and
practice it on its own and maybe we have
to practice it very slowly or in stages
at first we strum the g chord or maybe
even just the first two notes of a g
chord or we drill roundhouse kicks on a
heavy bag or maybe before that we work
on balancing on one leg but as soon as
we can put that g chord into the context
of the song or practice that roundhouse
kick in a sparring match we should do
that
so even if we aren't able to integrate
right away our goal is to integrate as
soon as possible and to practice only
the skills that we will integrate there
are a potentially infinite number of
ways to isolate in the above example you
could strum a g chord using three
strings on the guitar
and just to be clear on our terms to
integrate means to perform something
within the context that it is intended
to be in and to isolate means to extract
something and practice it on its own so
you can get it up to speed
isolation is a tool for learning a skill
or technique by itself but the problem
is that a person can get caught in a
pattern of isolation and begin learning
skills or techniques for the sake of
learning them without actually producing
anything with them or using them for any
sort of greater project
an example would be practicing every
conceivable taekwondo kick rather than
learning only the few you need to win
sparring matches or strumming every
conceivable guitar chord instead of
practicing only the few you need to play
your grandma's favorite elvis song
generalism isn't about learning every
skill or technique in the world just
because
it's about being better at just the
right number of things and then
combining those things to form a
competitive and creative advantage so
that means figuring out the fundamental
skills and then the fundamental
practices within them
writing is a fundamental skill but you
don't need to learn every word in the
dictionary to be good at it in fact you
probably already know all the words you
need to be an effective wordsmith you
just need to arrange them more clearly
which is a matter of integration not
isolation
though maybe you don't know enough words
so you do need to spend some time with a
dictionary or thesaurus but even if
that's the case you shouldn't spend any
more time with that book than you need
to get the job done simply as you begin
writing and come to discover you can't
think of the word you want you should
then open the reference to find it in
other words the practice of isolation is
informed by the practice of integration
when you need a word find it but don't
spend all your time finding words you
don't need
integration tells you what to isolate
because if you're integrating that is
practicing something within the context
of an outcome and realize you're coming
up short on a particular skill or
technique then you'll know what skill or
technique to isolate again using the
example of an ac dc song if you're
strumming along to dirty deeds done dirt
cheap and realize you're struggling
because you don't know how to play a
chord on the end of one that tells you
it's time to isolate playing chords on
the and of one until you've got the
rhythm so perfected that you can play
the chord in context without even
thinking about it
but you wouldn't sit around isolating
every possible rhythmic configuration on
the guitar that would be wasteful
instead you let the integration tell you
what to practice in isolation and then
you practice in isolation for as long as
you need until you can achieve
integration make sense yes no some grunt
of acknowledgement would be nice
how we isolate and how we integrate will
themselves be informed by the next and
last principle of generalism repetition
and resistance
let's not get ahead of ourselves the
principles have flowed in this order
because i have decided that's the order
in which they should flow which makes
perfect sense of course
it's a sort of top-down hierarchy if you
will where we start by understanding
what our goal is skill stacking over
specialization how to achieve it
generally short-term specialization how
much to achieve of it the rule of 80
and then how to proceed specifically
integration over isolation and finally
repetition and resistance
principle 5 repetition and resistance
when i began working out people couldn't
believe it because of all my friends i
was always the most out of shape i was
never good at sports and i was clumsy
and hefty so none of my so-called chums
took me seriously when i started going
to the weight room in fact nobody did
but as time went by i began losing
weight and building strength after not
too long all the people who initially
doubted were soon asking for advice and
what i would say is this you need to
understand repetition and resistance
that's our starting point if you want to
get stronger if you want to build skill
because remember this principle extends
far beyond the weight room you need to
practice what you want to get good at
and you need to find ways of making it
harder as you go so when it comes to
working out you need to do the exercises
that are challenging and you need to
make them more challenging because
eventually you'll adapt in other words
you need to do reps and add weight
part of the reason people don't progress
in the gym or otherwise is that they're
doing reps but not adding weight they're
in a routine but they're not making
their routine challenging they're not
using progressive resistance in other
words they're just keeping things the
same they keep military pressing the
same way or keep doing the same number
of push-ups or keep running the same
number of miles well it's similar with
any other skill repetition will only get
you so far if you want to get stronger
then you need to add weight to what
you're doing
i think a lot of people understand that
to improve at a skill you have to
practice it but i don't think a lot of
people understand that to really improve
you have to find ways to practice that
skill under increasingly difficult
demands it's not enough to merely write
you also have to try writing at a higher
level or in different styles it's not
enough to merely pluck notes on the
guitar you also have to pluck notes at
different tempos and time signatures
it's not enough to merely practice what
you're already good at you have to
practice the things that strain your
capabilities the things that you're not
already good at
here's the litmus test
if you ever have a practice session in
anything and you're not challenged by it
then you're not using the principle of
repetition and resistance you're not
really practicing at least not in an
optimal way so you can ignore all the
terrific nonsense one is so accustomed
to hearing about only perfect practice
being effective because whoever said
that never did it work out with any
significant weight when you're
struggling your practice is never going
to be perfect but it is going to improve
at the same time your goal should always
be to improve the quality of your
repetitions even as you are met with
difficulty to keep your knees out as you
squat more weight to keep your notes
clear as you build speed in other words
to not allow intensity to produce slop
there will of course be some competition
between consistency on the one hand and
intensity on the other it is obviously
easier to maintain the high quality of
your reps if you always keep your reps
the same but that would be defeating the
purpose at the same time however you
should never give yourself permission to
slack on quality just because the
assignment is difficult if you want to
make progress in the gym you need to
employ progressive overload that is
increasing resistance in fact if you
want to make progress at anything you
need to employ increasing resistance as
well but how you apply increasing
resistance will depend on the skill and
how far along you are with it we'll talk
specifics later but for now there are
some general factors that can help you
gauge what is appropriate and what isn't
to start i would suggest memorizing the
following motto challenged but
successful
training to failure is often training to
fail that is purposely pushing past your
known limits rather than working
intelligently up to them is a mistake
thus a secret to successful practicing
if there is one is to push yourself up
to but not necessarily beyond your
capabilities if quality has become
degraded in an exercise because of the
intensity at which you're doing it then
you are no longer getting better at the
exercise your serving slop
and the goal of an exercise is not to
serve slop the goal is to get better at
the exercise squats chord sequences
writing sentences whatever it is
occasionally you may exceed your limits
that's called strategic overreach and
that's not always a bad thing but it can
be a bad thing if that's all you're
doing challenged but successful
challenged but successful challenged but
successful
but let's not forget about repetition
either which resistance is destined to
rely on you can't add weight to
something you're not doing or something
you're not already familiar with and
that's the point of repetition you need
to practice specifically whatever it is
you want to get better at do reps at the
things you want to improve
do reps at the thing you want to improve
do reps at the thing you want to improve
don't expect to get better at pull-ups
by running aside from indirect carryover
that is for example running may help a
person lose weight which in turn would
make pull-ups easier but running itself
does not develop the strength for
pull-ups that may sound ludicrous who
would ever think to do something so
silly as that but we make this mistake
all the time we avoid doing the things
we're not good at and continue to
practice our strengths hoping that one
day our areas of weakness will somehow
take care of themselves but this simply
confuses solving a problem with ignoring
it the rule of repetition takes that
option away if you want to get good at
something you have to practice it all
right let's wrap this chapter up i think
we've laid the necessary groundwork to
launch into the specifics of this
fantabulous little enterprise generalism
the principles are there and they're
what we're going to be basing our
practice upon
what comes next is more difficult not in
a theoretical sense but in a practical
sense because the onus will soon be put
entirely on you
i hope i've been exceptionally clear
about this just reading this book won't
actually make you better at things did
anybody think that coming in oh god i
certainly hope not because if so boy are
you going to be disappointed when you
see just how much i'm about to ask you
to do the good news the work will be
efficient we'll adhere to these
principles
so our efforts will be swift and
scientific no time will be wasted and no
energy will be dispersed simply because
we feel like experimenting with things
there are no experiments here just a
process and it is to that process that
we now turn
chapter five where to begin meta skills
in my house up in the attic there's a
picture of me from around the third
grade i don't remember having this
picture taken probably because i never
wanted it taken i don't recall how it
got into my house since it's a school
portrait that probably my mom should
have hanging above the staircase next to
my sister bridget's
but somehow it found its way onto my
desk and i haven't been able to put it
away because for some reason when i look
at it i can't help but feel a certain
way about it why is that is it because i
knew this kid would have a somewhat
shaky start in life not exactly this
isn't about feeling bad for myself this
is about wanting to elevate myself so if
i ever could go back in time i'd be able
to assure this little version of me that
everything would turn out more or less
okay
now a lot of people some much more
successful than me hang portraits of
their heroes on the wall so it might
seem a little perverse some might even
say a little narcissistic for me to find
motivation in staring at a picture of
myself
but i look at it only because it serves
a purpose this photo of me in an ugly
brown and white sweater vest
smiling a stretched and dimpled smile
full of naivete and annoyance serves as
a self-reminder to work hard and become
the sort of person whom this young boy
would be proud of if he knew exactly how
his life was going to turn out
it reminds me that i don't want to be
just successful that i don't want to be
just good at things that i want to do
what's important what matters
i'm over being remembered or famous if
it happens great mostly i want to make a
difference and to do that i need to show
up every day and put in the work that
would inspire my younger self and cause
me to look forward to
at the very least not be worried about
the person i was about to become more
than anything i'd want to be able to
assure my younger self that my life
would have meaning that i would do
something and that this something would
matter
in the previous pages i've made the
argument that meaning is found in
freedom and not the kind of freedom most
americans would think of freedom comes
in knowing and making and doing good
things and all of that is more
aristotelian than it is uniquely
american americans are how's the best
way to put this
headstrong
rebelliously independent we don't like
to be told what to do i get that believe
me i don't like to be told what to do
either especially by some guy in a book
let alone one i've never met
but these types of freedom freedom of
indifference and freedom for excellence
are not mutually exclusive they're just
different types
and one as we've argued is merely
requisite for another
i said you need skills to express
yourself to do and know and make good
things and to the extent you have more
skills rather than fewer skills well all
the better wouldn't you say
when this is stated simply i think most
would agree even we rebellious americans
we also start to go against the
conventional perspective of achievement
when we talk about generalism or the
idea that it is actually better to ask
hardcore lifelong specialization
and to just get okay maybe even good to
great at a lot of things and then find
ways to combine them it's good to have
skills and know things so far i've
presented a series of principles for
developing skills so all that has been
very general now i'd like to get
specific and here's how i think we
should go about it
when i first began talking about
generalism on my blog a lot of people
asked how i would approach public
education since so much of what i was
saying seemed contrary to what we're
taught in school particularly college
we're instructed to specialize we're
told that if we want to get ahead we
need to narrow our interests not widen
them the whole thing is very screwing
it's why people get degrees in subjects
like economics and it's why people then
get even more specialized in their
degrees upon graduating like studying
international trade theory for instance
i think this is a misstep for a lot of
people not because the world doesn't
need specialists but because it probably
doesn't need another international trade
theorist telling us how to run the world
economy
we've had just about enough of those
thank you very much
to answer this question of how i would
approach education i think it might be
instructive and perhaps entertaining to
take a lesson from mr rogers and enter
the neighborhood of make believe where
i'm the principal no take that back
imperial viceroy of all the schools in
the world the world school system let's
call it and since we're in the
neighborhood of make-believe we can
simply ignore any small technical hiccup
that might arise in an actual top-down
centrally planned regime
because even if thought experiments like
this one are not practical on a societal
level that doesn't mean they can't
impart knowledge on a personal one by
explaining how i would educate all god's
children that is how i would teach
generalism generally my hope is that
you'll see how this would apply to you
individually that is how you would
become a generalist specifically
the idea behind my world school system
would be to bring kids up through a
hierarchy of skills whereupon the
foundation would be skills that are
essential and helpful to anyone these we
shall call meta skills
and then the skills would become more
particular and specific and probably
exciting as we go
this is how we should create a skill
stack first we build the bottom and
focus on all the skills that apply to
everyone skills like focus and logic and
faith
those last two may sound contradictory
to some but you'll see why they're not
from there we plop on our personal
interests maybe we want to be musicians
or cage fighters or whatever wonderful
let's spend time developing those
interest skills
finally as it is in most situations
there are filler or need-based skills
required the skills needed to bridge the
gap between being good at something and
getting paid to do it
so these are the types of skills
meta skills fundamental skills that are
helpful to everyone for example
persuasion interest skills
skills you are interested in and love
doing for example playing the ukulele
need-based skills
skills needed to make a living around
your interest for example marketing and
promotion looking at the above skill
stack if a person were good at the
ukulele but also knew a thing about
persuasion and how to advertise they
would have almost everything they need
to garner a paycheck by playing their
adorable little instrument even if
they're not the best in the world at it
that would be the objective of my world
school system to teach all the kids
skills every human should possess
develop the skills each individual is
particularly interested in and layer on
any other skills needed for each person
to make a living by doing what they love
that's a skill stack
your first day at school a letter from
the imperial viceroy
welcome to your first day as part of the
world school system i'm glad you made it
as if you had any other choice you're
here now that's all that matters and
we're all together isn't that nice i
think that is just so nice
since we have so many formative years
ahead of us i thought we should take a
few moments to get to know one another
and to understand the reason why we're
here because the job of course of the
world school system is to guide our
youth that's you toward competency
productivity fulfillment and being a
useful not too annoying citizen the goal
is to get the stars to align so to speak
to ensure that all our students find
that just right mix of success and
happiness and peace so here i am looking
at you and i can see on all your smiling
faces the look of carbonated optimism
that is optimism right or do you need to
use the bathroom okay you go to the
bathroom but everybody else stay where
you are and keep looking optimistic
because i think optimism is just
wonderful i think we can all have trust
and some providential hand to play even
if we must not think everything's going
to be done for us i think we must view
the world in a certain very particular
way and i think a quid pro quo
perspective might help in other words
the universe gives to those who go out
and get there are no metaphysical
handouts so to speak only hand ups
you may not always get what you want but
you'll almost certainly get what you
deserve and a few things you don't so
yes providence is there but you have to
respond to it you have to take the time
to develop yourself and accept
challenges and build character here's a
scene in the 1967 version of the movie
jungle book which is far too old for
most of you to remember where a boy
mowgli has escaped into the wild and
joined an army of elephants lined up
single file the elephant in charge
colonel hottie is pacing up and down
lecturing his troops at one point he
examines the trunk of a rookie elephant
and associates it with a dusty firearm
soldier he says remember in battle that
trunk can save your life then after a
short ramble about earning his
commission in the maharajah's fifth
pachyderm brigade he exclaims it was
then that i received the victorian cross
for bravery above and beyond the call of
duty aha those were the days discipline
discipline was the thing builds
character and all that sort of thing you
know
in that short scene colonel hadi has
given us one of the great secrets to
life it's about discipline because
discipline builds character and all that
sort of thing you know
discipline in other words equals freedom
the freedom to express yourself the
freedom to do good things and make good
thing and to know what good things are
discipline is one of the first meta
skills we're going to learn because
discipline one could say is the most
fundamental the most essential of all
the skills a human can have since
without discipline what do you have who
you have are improperly ordered values
and priorities what you have is a lack
of ethic to deny what's gratifying in
lieu of what's important and that my
little elephant is a problem
you are a slave to your animal instincts
we'll work up to that shortly and don't
worry this isn't boot camp but we do
have standards after discipline comes
focus which is in some ways an extension
of discipline so we can think of focus
as discipline applied or discipline
concentrated focus will prevent us from
getting distracted we'll examine that a
few moments next is logic because if we
can learn logic we can learn how to
learn it's the skill that takes care of
so many other skills above the
fundamental level without logic we're
lost we'll fall for pretty much anything
but with logic or found we can figure
things out and not say or do generally
unintelligent things that's all logic is
thinking done right and done well
next and this is the one i'm sure
everybody will be interested in is
persuasion essentially how do you get
along with people how do you get people
to like you sometimes people think of
persuasion as a series of psychological
tricks or cliches or manipulation
strategies but that's not really
persuasion persuasion is about taking a
stand and having a voice and making what
you say attractive to people or at least
some people
finally we have faith yup and this is
the big one faith is what undergirds and
reinforces all efforts and creations and
orients those efforts and creations
toward the continuous and purposeful
development of self it's what stops us
from chasing the wrong things in life
like becoming a career prostitute or
congressperson part in the redundancy
faith is what keeps us going it gives us
a sense of surety when it seems the
world has gone completely insane which
trust me it has so maybe also trust me
when i say you're going to need faith
and you're going to need to have to work
at it it's why we think of faith as a
skill
now i get that none of these fundamental
skills may seem particularly appealing
at first especially to children who
really wants to study logic but i can
promise you this once you see how useful
these meta skills are for getting pretty
much whatever you want out of life they
will become not only interesting but
immensely so think of it this way learn
logic and never lose an argument again
even if nobody else knows it and even if
it's only because you'll learn exactly
what arguments not to make wouldn't that
be a nice position to be in
lastly we'll work on these skills
through the principles of generalism by
applying short-term specialization the
rule of 80
integration over isolation repetition
and resistance and what's that other one
again ah yes
skill stacking is greater than
specialization how could i forget
because that one is really what this
school is about we're not over much
concerned with any of you becoming the
best at anything because well let's be
honest here that isn't what this is
about we merely want you to be
exceedingly competent across a wide
swath of human abilities so you can
combine those skills to whatever just so
happens to interest you and be not only
productive but fulfilled let's begin
discipline
you're not going to have a lot of
discipline at first this is just a fact
you're going to have a tough time
keeping your butt in the chair or
getting your butt to the gym because
your butt has a mind of its own and this
we call butt mind which is notorious for
offering temptations and reasons to
procrastinate this is where we need to
step in and assertively protest no you
listen to me but mind i am in control
you listen to me now
and i think this is pretty much what
discipline is about getting your butt to
sit when it would rather run and getting
your butt to run when it would rather
sit
but mind is not just a metaphor it's
something we all say to ourselves
probably a lot more often than we think
it goes yes but
what is discipline discipline is this
putting yourself in a position to follow
orders and hopefully eventually your own
we need discipline because we can't
acquire skill without routine we can't
find meaning without something to work
on something we feel is significant like
writing a novel becoming religious or
baking a cake without discipline we're
just wishy-washy life will toss us
whichever way it wants
discipline gives us meaning then because
it gives us something to do through
discipline we work at our craft and can
make things we also learn things
and through discipline we develop a
routine that makes sense of our day we
wake up steep the coffee grounds and
start on something big and fantastic we
sit our butts in the seat or use them to
do kettlebell swings maybe toward the
evening there's time for dessert but
let's just see how the day goes before
we make any decisions about that
discipline sets the agenda and that's
what makes us productive and creative
whoever has found discipline has found
freedom discipline in fact equals
freedom and there's actually now a guy
who writes books on this idea and he's a
former navy seal and people love him
he also happens to be fairly
intimidating so when he says discipline
equals freedom you're likely to believe
him now i'm not particularly
intimidating so i wouldn't expect i
could just say something and have you
take my word for it but hopefully by
this point i've made a good argument
because i've said about a million times
the person with freedom is not the
person who chooses to do whatever they
want but the person who chooses to not
do whatever they want
freedom is found in restriction
restriction that leads to the practice
of something useful
if you want freedom you need boundaries
that force you to improve you need to
impose rules upon yourself and you need
to adhere to those rules as if they were
enforced by someone in uniform
so like i said you're not going to have
a lot of discipline at first nobody does
you're probably going to start out a
pretty indolent sac like me he'll slink
by he'll do the minimum he'll cheat on
your exams by peering over a person's
shoulder and if they're bratty about it
they'll wrap their arms around their
tests so you can't see what they're
writing
but one day something will hit you where
it hurts and you'll realize you've been
wasting your life with this attitude of
mere survival and disinterest in getting
better at things we can say this is your
awakening you'll feel degenerate and
awful which believe it or not is a good
thing i mean it's certainly better to
feel degenerate and awful now while you
can still do something about it and to
feel degenerate and awful on your
deathbed
let's take a few minutes right now to
all feel degenerate and awful so we
don't wind up like that everyone feel it
the terribleness okay good
because sometimes you need to meditate
not just on what you do want but on all
the things you don't want to get
yourself inspired the problem with
calling discipline a skill is that it
leads us into somewhat of a paradox
because what do you need to develop
skill if not discipline and if
discipline is a skill and you don't have
discipline then how in the name of jonah
and the whale do you even get started on
such a thing i'll tell you
you go back to that deteriorated and
abysmal sense of self the lack as i call
it you look yourself dead in the eye
most people will need a mirror for this
and say enough is enough you sack of
mildewed [ __ ] it's time to get it
together
discipline is empowered by passion
sometimes that passion starts as a
negative and as you improve it goes into
a chrysanthemum or whatever they call it
and turns into this big huge beautiful
and bountiful thing becomes gorgeous and
worth pursuing becomes something you
want to chase rather than something that
chases you but at first yes most of us
find discipline by trying to avoid some
ugly and significant god-awful no-good
terrible pain in our lives so the more
we meditate on that pain the less we
stop trying to ignore it or avoid it and
the more passion we have for our pursuit
maybe you're like i was maybe you're
sick of being slower less informed and
less skilled than almost everyone maybe
you want to just be happy for a while to
feel that your life has meaning and that
you actually did something terrific and
awesome like whoever invented
disinfectant wipes that guy should be
super proud because honestly that's
enough you can't really ask for anything
more but you need to focus on that sense
of inadequacy like visualize it you know
yes it'll suck it'll sound like the
reverse of all self-help advice that
says you should envision your future
with mansions atop waterfalls but it'll
get you going when you don't feel like
you have the discipline to start it'll
motivate you more than mansions atop
waterfalls you're just going to have to
trust me on that pain is the only way
out the buddha taught us that and he
said nirvana is found through the way of
samsara he made a compelling point
i remember working with a guy he wasn't
exactly a life coach but he kind of was
who had me do an exercise in which i
brought to mind five life instances when
i was embarrassed or ashamed because of
my lack of initiative
five times when i really wish i had done
something but i didn't or couldn't act
he then had me review those scenes
repeatedly to build disgust to the point
that i simply had to do something about
it and so i did i remember the time i
failed to ask a girl to the fifth grade
dance and then somebody else did the
time i got cut from the basketball team
and so on and so forth i kept rewinding
and reviewing those scenes over and over
and the very next day almost entirely
out of the blue i signed up for
taekwondo because to me that seemed
ideal why not start with this one very
simple and humble skill and then use it
to kick the ass of everybody who ever
made fun of me how perfect
as mentioned earlier i started working
out because i hated the way i looked and
i hated that everybody was better than
me at everything i wanted to be better
than them at i hated being picked on
pushed around and picked last for pretty
much everything i didn't feel fondly
about any of these things at the time
but i remember them fondly now they led
me into that chrysanthemum remember they
changed me from a fat and disheveled
teenage derelict with a fairly
significant dandruff problem to somebody
with something to show for myself in
this case a yellow belt
as i started to lose weight i started to
gain confidence what happens when you
gain confidence your discipline improves
when you gain confidence you gain
discipline a different discipline a
discipline that comes from being excited
about what you can do not what you're
trying to run away from the whole thing
eventually flips over on itself like a
pancake and now one side is beautifully
firm and brown because you've been
cooking it it's no longer clumpy
amorphous
all of us must start with a belief that
we can in fact do something about
ourselves and that it's never too late
to start no matter how ragged you feel
no matter how run down you're never past
the point of rescue unless you're say 93
maybe then we might want to consider
other options but so long as you're not
93 and maybe even if you're 92 it's
never too late to turn the operation
around and become the person you've
wanted to be i'll give you an example
i have a much older friend who was
really overweight his entire life more
than 50 years
and in just these last two years he's
lost 100 pounds and his attitude and
outlook and everything it's just so cool
to see he has confidence now he's out
doing things he's pursuing goals
learning skills starting a health
business even and when i asked why he
was able to succeed this time after
starting and stopping so many times
before he said it was because he finally
gave himself permission to succeed he
said every time he tried to lose weight
before he always doubted that he could
do it never really believe now i didn't
get a chance to conduct a full and
proper psychoanalysis on him but if i
had to guess i think it was that he
finally realized he was worth investing
in
he also had something of a religious
perspective so that helped give yourself
permission to believe
it should also be mentioned of course
that he trained with me i do seem to
have a knack for getting people to lose
weight i'm like the fat person whisperer
i can say that because i used to be more
than just hefty myself but don't you say
that it might come off a little
insensitive
finally how do you get started the
question answers itself
get started and get started on something
that interests you because discipline
isn't a skill you develop in isolation
it's a skill you develop through
integration through the practice of
something specific like karate you don't
sit down and do discipline because what
would that look like it would look like
you were just sitting there unless that
sitting involves meditating you're not
actually practicing discipline
you'd have to be doing something to be
practicing discipline right
so sit down and write or strum the
guitar get up and exercise and that is
practicing discipline
the secret is to start with whatever
rouses the emotions whatever infuses you
with passion
there are other things we can do as well
like for example following an exercise
program here's an idea make the first
act you do every day in active
discipline this can be a workout or
meditation or a cold shower in fact i
think it should be a workout and a
meditation because why not both
so let's put that into the schedule
let's say that at the start of the day
we do a little exercise and then spend a
little time focused on our breathing
we'll start with the sweaty stuff and
then become super silent it won't take
long say a 10 to 15 minute workout
followed by a 10 to 15 minute meditation
we're talking 30 minutes max
i remember when i used to spend the
night at my grandparents house i'd come
downstairs in the morning to find my
grandfather working out he did a simple
routine but he did it every morning with
no exceptions or complaints he'd start
with some push-ups and then he'd use
hand weights and finish on the ground
and stretch like a frog
it wasn't the most laborious workout
i've ever seen but then again it didn't
have to be he was very active otherwise
so this was just the start of his day a
way to get himself going
small acts of discipline undertaken
every day do magical and fantastic
things to our unconscious mind
having the discipline to do the work
kick starts the creative process a
writer friend of mine said good ideas
are rewarded to those with a disciplined
mind it's not something you just happen
into he said if you want to invoke the
muse you have to show that you are
worthy of handling what she gives you
and the only way to do that is to show
up every day and to be on time he said
it's like waiting outside a zen
monastery you're going to be tested and
likely you'll think you'll never get in
but eventually if you keep showing up
those doors will open even if only to
slide you a piece of bread the good
ideas will come i promise at least he
promises
this means that you need to get better
at showing up for whatever you want to
get better at that's discipline and we
practice by starting something and
finishing what we start because next to
starting finishing is the hardest thing
maybe even harder than starting itself
the only thing that isn't hard to finish
is sex
so in one sense i'm just super at
finishing but in another i'm still
working on it like anybody
because you get started and you get so
far along and then you quit because well
you know life is hard that's why we need
discipline it's about the only thing
that can get us through
exercise can help we can torture
ourselves physically to acquire grit
that always works
certainly it does in the military we can
do exercises that are just plain
excruciating and see if we can go 10
seconds longer or 10 pounds heavier than
we think every time or every other time
or what have you
front squats hollow holds pretty much
any of these will do the trick whatever
hurts whatever you hate doing go with
that
as we move into the other sections that
is the other meta skills you will find
particular ways of practicing discipline
note that your initial discipline must
come by pursuing what's important all
the other meta skills can follow and
they will follow as you become
interested in them and you should become
interested in them because they're fun
skills to have and like super useful
here's one quick and very important part
of developing discipline track and
monitor everything
[Music]
[Music]
what workouts you're doing all your
income and expenses if you're playing
guitar record your practice sessions if
you're practicing a martial art then get
yourself on videotape what gets measured
gets managed as they say and you know
what they are right tracking builds not
only awareness but accountability it
also illuminates progress it gives you
something to celebrate
so one last word about discipline before
we move on let's talk about moderation
you know that whole idea of just dipping
your toe in starting slow and so on well
i've got to go ahead and say i think the
concept is mostly if not entirely
worthless a disciplined person is one of
extremes often even a person obsessed
when it's time to go we go all the way
short-term specialization remember
now none of that means we've got to be
perfect or can never enjoy a little
something sweet after we've eaten our
protein and vegetables it just means
that when we commit we don't commit 70
we commit 100
even if we can only give 70 sometimes
it's the intention that counts this is
different from the rule of 80 we learned
earlier just to clarify
this is why when i'm talking fitness or
business and people ask how long it will
take to reach their goal i give them an
estimate of about double the time i
honestly expect this is sort of my
assessment device because if you care
about something if you found that
boiling hot cauldron of passion then
spending double the amount of time on
developing that something should be no
big deal right
if you ask me how long it will take to
become happy and successful and totally
fulfilled and i reply until you're 93
would you still be interested
would you still engage in everything
we're about to do
the good news i'm convinced anybody can
achieve freedom and happiness that
anybody can become a successful
generalist and a sufficiently
disciplined person with about an hour or
two of practice a day my only request is
that you should be willing to give eight
i provided some brief examples for
developing each skill discussed in this
chapter to give you a kickstart
the daily discipline checklist
one establish a regular bedtime get at
least seven to eight hours of sleep
preferably wake up before 5am and go to
bed before 10 pm
2. exercise at least 30 minutes a day 3.
meditate or pray at least 10 minutes a
day
4.
have protein at every meal
5. take a cold shower or a shower with a
cold finish that is use cold water for
the last two minutes
six walk ten thousand steps a day
seven each day do without something you
quote unquote need hint iphone tv etc
eight make your bed
nine do the most difficult and important
thing of the day first
ten
keep a gratitude journal
here's some recommended additional
reading check out discipline equals
freedom a field manual by jaco willink
focus
if there's anything i've noticed about
life it's that most of us probably think
too much and that most of the thinking
we do isn't super abundantly helpful in
fact it would seem that most of our
thoughts are jealous clingy eerily
narcissistic or otherwise focused on
things that aren't that important like
what we would say if we ever got the
chance to beat richard nixon whether we
missed the boat on getting orthodontia
or whatever
thinking is a skill and one will soon
get into but not thinking is also a
skill and that's called focus
others might refer to this as meditation
but meditation is more of a technique
used to develop the skill
focus can be used to make ourselves
smart and to stop from going insane it's
a powerful skill and one that is left
curiously undeveloped in most people
with focus we can concentrate on what
matters and not give in to our
concupiscable appetites as much we can
say no to sin father arul would be proud
father arul is a priest friend of mine
short guy mostly bald indian maybe you
know because with focus we can sit our
butts in the seat and not get up for
anything focus is the skill that lets us
do the work once we've got the
discipline to show
here's the biggest difference between
winners and losers in life the winners
know how to keep their butts situated
when it's time to write or get their
butts in the gym when it's time to train
the losers procrastinate they get
distracted they stop before the job is
done and that's it now part of that is
discipline the other part is focus
because here's the thing and i don't
know how else to put this there are
enemies out there trying to do
everything they can to stop us from
succeeding demonic forces i'm convinced
that delight in our undoing and that we
absolutely must battle against if we
want to survive sounds serious well it's
true author stephen pressfield calls
this universal negative force resistance
and maybe i'm a bit old school but i
just think of this bastard as the devil
now we can see that most public school
systems have gotten away from offering
instruction on demonology and personally
i find that just a little irresponsible
because i very much believe the devil
was out there buzzing around with his
big leathery wings or occasionally
walking on his buttocks like red guy
from i am weasel doing everything he can
to either scam torment or destroy us
and he'll use whatever he can to do it
too so mostly he'll work through
secondary means using such sly
instruments as complacency self-doubt
and as we know the dmv these are just a
few among his beloved pets also the
dishwasher repair guy but the most
amazing trick the devil has ever pulled
is getting us to believe that he doesn't
exist
that one you can bring to the bank
i really think so much of success is
engaging in some level of spiritual
warfare but mind the universe hades
resistance satan whatever this ongoing
negative opposition is and however you
want to envision it is a real thing and
is constantly attempting to thwart our
efforts to make something of ourselves
it throws every distraction and
assignment on our plate at once it's the
reason there's never a good time to
start a diet plan write a book or pick
up a musical instrument and it's the
reason there never will be
our job is to do whatever we can to piss
the devil off and let them know that
we're simply not going to stand for this
abuse
that no matter the amount of smelly
garbage he tries to pile in front of us
we're going to remain focused we're
going to stay on the job and we're going
to finish what we start
it's not only the goings-on of life to
get us distracted it's our thinking as
well most of us have next to no control
over the thoughts that flit through our
head we're possessed by that probably we
feel we could benefit from an exorcism
at times and perhaps some of us could a
little exorcism now and then never hurt
but the good news is that most of us
just need to learn to focus through the
techniques of meditation and or prayer
because it usually goes something like
this
you decide you want to do something
let's take writing for example say
you're excited really excited because
you just read a book that motivated your
socks off and now you're going to
practice skill and you're going to write
a novel you know i think that sounds
just as well
you haul your bony little butt up to the
attic sit down and turn on your computer
you open a word document crack your
knuckles and realize you forgot your cup
of coffee darn so you schlep downstairs
into the kitchen and brew something nice
for yourself not once noticing how the
devil has already scored a point against
you now you're back in the attic ready
to write and then a social media
notification oh joy somebody commented
on a thread you started in the dog
lovers group your sister added you to
how nice so you take a peek to see what
they said imagining it to be pleasant
and interesting and not intending to
start a conversation because you've got
work to do you click on the person's
profile only to discover that their
entire timeline is just one long
quivering insane rant against everything
you stand for politically and
religiously as well
well that just about does it
you blast them with everything you've
got barraging them from completely out
of left field and then slam your
computer shut alright now that that's
done time for business there's only one
problem you can't get that reptilian
idiot out of your head the excitement
you had the jolity over the project has
all turned to rage and you can't stop
thinking about all the things you wish
you had said to that person and their
dumb little dog you could have for
example illuminated them with the
minorly helpful fact that the only
reason they exist is to serve as one
hilarious and pathetic example of what
not to look like and so it's no wonder
they own a corgi you're just so enraged
this isn't how your morning was supposed
to go this isn't how you wanted to write
and then the doorbell well look you
decided to show if it is in our old
friend the dishwasher repair guy and on
and on it goes your day bombarded and
beleaguered by all these distractions
and disappointments and doubt oh you
think this is coincidence do you okay
sure
that's where focus comes in it's pretty
much the only weapon we have to be able
to stay on target to sit and stay seated
or run and keep running and this believe
me is a skill it's not something any of
us have it's something we develop here's
how first we sit cross-legged tall
kneeling on a rocking chair look it
doesn't matter just don't lie in
savasana like at the end of some
hedonistic yoga ritual father rule would
be very upset
plus why run the risk of becoming
possessed by a throng of demons it's not
like we don't already have enough to
worry about
second we do something to center
ourselves here we could focus on
breathing or reciting a mantra or prayer
for people who are particularly prone to
overthinking yes hello
i recommend speaking out loud it gives
you something a little more solid to
hold on to the whole mindful breathing
thing is a bit much starting out it's
too easy to get distracted but if it
works for you great
or you could start with some sort of
guided meditation that can be helpful
here's a plan for practicing focus and
meditation upon waking engage in 10
minutes of mindfulness meditation and or
prayer then during the day practice
trigger meditations for example doorway
mantras or prayers every time you walk
through a doorway recite a mantra or say
a prayer returning to the present moment
two-minute car meditations are also a
good idea every time you're about to
leave the car or at least twice per day
take two minutes to practice mindfulness
meditation and also before bed engage in
a mindfulness prayer based tea ritual an
hour or so before bed it'll help with a
lot and especially sleep
a recommended resource for this would be
how to pray reflections and essays by
c.s lewis
it's pretty simple we sit for at least
five to ten minutes first thing in the
morning and let whatever thoughts happen
to come come
we don't try to push them away we don't
try to hold on to them either instead we
simply note them we build awareness and
welcome them lovingly but also don't pay
too much attention to them oh hello
anxiety come right in
cup of tea perhaps
it's this warm empathetic invitation
that gives us headspace
we're after clarity and independence of
mind
we're after a state where we're no
longer so entangled with our emotions
that they dictate our every behavior and
where we can dispassionately observe
them almost as if we're standing on the
sidewalk watching the cars go by
because most of the time it feels like
we're standing right in the middle of
the road doesn't it dodging and swerving
and throwing our hands up yelling stop
focus is simply about standing off to
the side where it's safe and not
alarming it's not about trying to halt
the traffic of your thinking which only
leads to congestion problems it's about
alleviating that congestion and letting
it cool off which it will you just need
to get out of its way you need to stop
getting so involved with the circulation
of thoughts you need to stop playing
traffic cop start your day with this
and do it again before lunch and then
after dinner remember the principles of
generalism repetition and resistance
start with a period of meditation and or
prayer that is challenging but leaves
you successful don't strive for too much
too soon you'll just get angry and
overwhelmed increase resistance by
meditating or praying for longer periods
or in more chaotic environments like
work the latter is when we get into
integration
i remember a talk from a holy man who
upon being asked how often he meditates
said he meditates all the time that he
was even meditating right at that moment
the person interviewing him was
astonished by this and his eyes widened
he looked aghast now this holy man could
have been making a bunch of stuff up
having once decided that so far as con
jobs go spiritual guru might work out
better in some respects than colonics
but say he wasn't say he was the real
deal
well and i think the point the holy man
was making is that meditation isn't
something you're supposed to do on the
side of a mountain meditation is
something you're supposed to practice
very nearly all the time
harnessing the power of focus is how we
snap our attention onto whatever
deserves it and pull our attention away
from anything that doesn't there's no
reason your work playing the piano
practicing with a potato gun shooting
pool
shouldn't be a point of meditation you
should also be focusing on whatever
skill you're working on but at first we
developed the skill by extracting the
principles and practicing them in a
seated or kneeling position at home in
church while waiting in the parking lot
as your spouse finishes the weekly
shopping and as soon as we're able we
apply this focus to every single
activity we can
this is how we break free of the prison
of our own minds this is how we overcome
anxiety and self-sabotage and avoid
turning into someone we really don't
want to be
it all starts in our mind here's a
little suggested schedule to help you
own your focus
logic
it was the philosopher norman l geisler
who told us why logic matters
simply put you can't avoid studying
logic so you might as well know what
you're doing it is the basis for all
other studies it is the basis for all
math and science even music from bach to
the beach boys is based on logic
without it there could be no rational
discussion of anything writing would be
impossible how can you put a sentence
together without a logical order
okay sold now where do we start
well we start by examining a few simple
rules of logical thinking and how
learning what makes for a good argument
and how to avoid a few of the more
common fallacies for example learning
the differences between induction and
deduction and why you shouldn't answer
an argument by attacking a person's
character the basics then
logic worksheet
here's a few questions to ask before
engaging in an argument on this subject
what are my biases
on this subject am i willing to accept
an outcome i dislike how could i argue
against my position
have i taken the time to best understand
my opponent's position
and just for fun here are 10 logical
fallacies that thou shalt never commit
1. red herring
that means intentionally distracting
away from the argument
2. non-sequitur arriving at a conclusion
not supported by the premises
3. the genetic fallacy attempting to
invalidate the position by explaining
how it came to originate for example you
think democracy is great only because
you grew up in america
it actually doesn't say anything about
whether democracy is good or bad
four the bandwagon fallacy assuming that
because many people believe something it
must be true
five composition fallacy assuming that
something is true of the whole because
it is true of some or all of the parts
for example if a team has all the best
players then that team will always win
ad hominen an attack on the person
attempting to undermine the character of
a person rather than addressing their
argument
false dilemma
claiming a situation to be either or
when there is at least one additional
option
circular reasoning or begging the
question
already assuming what you are attempting
to prove in other words offering no
evidence distinct from the conclusion
for example sandusky is in ohio
therefore sandusky is in ohio
appeal to authority assuming that just
because someone is in a position of
authority they are therefore correct
finally straw man that is setting up an
artificially weak version of an opposing
argument therefore making it easier to
refute
how to practice making arguments here's
a good idea join a facebook debate group
there's plenty of them engaged daily
or record at least one logical fallacy
in conversation per day
perhaps you engage in frequent
consensual low stakes arguments with
friends or family
or write a weekly well-reasoned opinion
piece on social media
here's some additional recommended
reading
check out the book come let us reason an
introduction to logical thinking by
norman l geisler and ronald m brooks
logic is ordering your thoughts it's
thinking done well and done right it's
what stops us from buying stupid things
and voting for stupid people and putting
our fingers in places that could shock
us
logic put frankly is life's foolproof
[ __ ] detector and since this is your
life
you've got to be able to think if you're
going to survive you've got to be able
to figure your way through things
you've got to know what makes for a good
argument and what sound reasoning is
logic used to be a skill taught to
almost everyone now almost no one
studies it the effects of this i think
are obvious and gross people are duped
by slick sounding folks with an
appealing accent on infomercials at
political rallies in the classroom this
is not good this is really not good we
all like to think that thinking is
important but very few of us ever learn
to do it well we never learn what logic
is or why it matters or how to use it or
how to tell when somebody else is using
it or not
it's a skill with carryover to think
clearly is to write clearly or at least
to have the potential to
it is also to have the potential to
persuade but we will have more to say on
that later
this is why logic is a meta skill
ordered thinking is how you make sense
of the world and how you make sense to
other people
you learn to think so you don't get
taken advantage of but also so you can
express yourself solve problems and
communicate there's a lot of benefit to
thinking about thinking so let's think
about it specifically let's think about
how to get better at it well one way and
this is going to sound simple but it
works is by practicing puzzles there are
many apps and games these days that set
you up with logical exercises starting
your day solving a few of these puzzles
will do a lot to build your critical
capacity most people spend no time with
exercises like these with questions like
if bob and john and matt are all
brothers and the following statements
are true who's the oldest
another one of the best ways to become a
better thinker is to engage in debate to
actually practice making arguments and
defending a position on something
so that's why in our little world school
system everybody is on the debate team
and everybody argues and is judged on
how they do and winners will be
celebrated and losers sentenced to some
sort of yet to be determined very likely
excruciating punishment probably
nobody gets out of this because this
will force students to intellectually
grind a question to pulp and that's
something we should all get in the habit
of doing
there will be a signed reading as well
the book in this class will be come let
us reason an introduction to logical
thinking by norman l geisler and ronald
m brooks
from there each student will engage in a
weekly debate with another student or as
part of a panel sometimes students will
get to pick their topic and other times
they won't since it's a good exercise to
argue for a position you don't
necessarily believe in in fact people
should be doing that as often as they
can
a good debate involves knowing not only
your position but the opposite as well
plus having to argue for a position you
don't agree with will either strengthen
your defense or cause you to adopt a
different point of view but either way
you're getting closer to getting things
right and that's what we want
like for any other skill we use
integration over isolation yes it's good
to study the rules of logic and each of
the many individual fallacies something
we don't really have time to cover in
detail now
you learn to be logical mostly by making
and defending arguments and trying to
get better at it pick a topic you're
interested in it can be spicy or it can
be dull you don't have to make every
argument about religion or politics
some arguments can be boring but made
well and that's fine it's all practice
often it's better to start with lower
key topics because emotions will be less
likely to erupt if for example you're
making an argument that oatmeal can
lower a person's blood sugar instead of
an argument that the minimum wage has
long-term effects on the american
economy
so you might be surprised
the next step is to increase resistance
raise the stakes seek out more rigorous
topics and opponents talk about the
minimum wage or religion force yourself
to establish a series of premises and
defend them doing this can be exhausting
but it makes you better sometimes you'll
lose that's fine so long as you always
take something away from it either an
opportunity to strengthen your argument
or change your position because well
because you were wrong
here's the thing the person who
practices logic understands that almost
all truth is discovered through the
gradual removal of error you figure out
what's right by being corrected and
adjusting your position on things nobody
is born with an answer to everything not
even father a rule
we have to figure out most of this as we
go along and be flexible and willing to
change
logic let me tell you is just as useful
for calling yourself out as it is for
calling out others we all get emotional
we all form attachments to things but we
mustn't let what we want to be true
determine our beliefs about what is
actually true
if logic does anything it gets you to
think before you open your mouth and
what a valuable skill that is it gets
you to assess your arguments before you
present them and what a valuable skill
that is
for instance right away a sense of logic
should stop a person from ever falling
for poor dietary advice even if they
don't have a degree in nutritional
science of course a degree in
nutritional science can help but we all
can't have a degree in everything we're
interested in and there are a lot of
things in life we're going to need to
figure out without having the time to be
formally educated in them this is why we
think about thinking so we can think
about things and do a good job thinking
about them or at least realize when we
don't have enough information to go on
logic can lead you to the right
conclusion
or often to the conclusion that you
don't know enough to form a conclusion
just yet and that's a wonderful and
prudent thing not getting ahead of
yourself
don't worry about never being able to
speak up for lack of certainty that's
not what logic is about an argument is
merely presenting reasons for assuming
that a position is true and making those
reasons as convincing as possible even
if they aren't absolute
say you want to argue for austrian
economics or the existence of god or
mega death over metallica you don't have
to establish a geometric proof for any
of these you only need to offer reasons
that make your position more plausibly
true than not and some will accept those
reasons and others will attempt to
refute them but hopefully everybody will
learn something and get along
i just want to emphasize the use of the
word argument before we wrap this
discussion up when most of us think
about arguing picture how badly our
extended family members behave around
the holidays shouting at each other over
their various religious and political
and economic beliefs never once
presenting anything in the realm of
acidity that's not what i mean when i
use that word i mean something that is
well presented and well debated
something well logical not something
people do when they're drunk not
something emotional
i've lost a lot of arguments and i think
i'm getting better at it the better i've
gotten at losing arguments the more i've
tended to win them the point of arguing
shouldn't be to win however that may be
the point of being on a debate team
that's not the point of arguing which
should be to figure out a position to
discover truth the best way to win an
argument is to not be wrong and the best
way to be right is to know when you're
not right logic can help you do that
persuasion
so far we've talked about discipline and
focus or patience and logic or reason
now we need to talk about persuasion
because it's hard to get what you want
in life without being able to convince
people to give it to you
that sounded odd let me put it this way
it's better to get along with people
than not it's better to have people like
you than not and if persuasion is
anything it's being liked by people even
if it's only some of them so here's how
to get people to like you and why this
doesn't involve being liked by everybody
all worthwhile attention starts by
telling the truth if you want to be
persuasive you need to have confidence
in what you're saying since people can
always tell when others aren't so sure
of themselves persuasion isn't about
getting everybody to like you persuasion
is about getting enough people to like
you because here's the problem people
fall into they think being persuasive
means to pander but pandering isn't
being persuasive pandering is having no
backbone no real true center of belief
it's not having enough conviction to say
what is true it's saying only what you
think people will like whether you
believe in it or not
nobody wants to be friends with somebody
like that or if they do it's only
because they want to get something out
of them like free coffee at work
people are attracted to those who have
something to say and who apparently
believe in that something
and if you have something to say people
are going to either agree with you or
disagree with you a good example love
him or hate him is donald trump very few
people like donald trump they want to
either marry him or send him to the
gulag i'm not saying you have to be like
donald trump to be persuasive but i'm
saying there's something you can learn
from donald trump who is persuasive
i'd like to note something about one of
donald trump's persuasion techniques
some people say he's a liar yet i just
said being persuasive starts with
telling the truth what gives well donald
trump has learned to make statements
that are often quote unquote
directionally true but specifically or
in other ways exaggerated this is a more
nuanced technique and not something we
have time to get into now but it is not
necessary to use this technique to be
persuasive and i do not particularly
agree with its use on an ethical level
so virtually every effective politician
engages in it anyway it's worth noticing
for more see the book pre-suasion a
revolutionary way to influence and
persuade by robert childini
the first thing is to become very okay
with the fact that not everybody is
going to like you and not everybody is
going to agree with what you have to say
because as soon as you have something to
say there's always someone who will
disagree with it even if you state the
earth is round there will be someone who
disagrees with it unfortunately and
someone who will be offended by it you
simply can't go through life worried
about who you're going to upset with
your beliefs the very act of having
beliefs is bound to upset somebody the
fact that you own things is upsetting to
someone and the fact i just said that is
upsetting to someone else instead of
worrying go through life getting clear
on your beliefs and the reasons you
would hear to them and then speak now
don't be an ignoramus however don't
voice an opinion without backup this is
why we use logic and reason because
you're going to need to know how to
defend yourself after you've offended
someone even if you've never intended to
back when i got into fitness a lot of my
original audience was drawn to me
because i was bold about what i believe
a lot of people were specializing i was
saying maybe try generalization for a
change this got me into no small number
of arguments but i always presented my
reasons lucidly i think without taking
personal digs people appreciated that
they liked that i was clear-headed and
that i was confident in what i had to
say even in the midst of debate and
let's be fair it was also very fit which
illustrated my beliefs
but so were many of the people i was
arguing against ultimately my appeal
came from standing for something
something people themselves seemed
interested in or at least curious about
i was speaking up for the generalists
and all the people who weren't the best
at anything but still wanted to improve
that's a lot of people
that's one little secret of mine when
you speak about something and you voice
your beliefs if those beliefs are held
by people in addition to yourself all
the better so much of persuasion is
finding people who already agree with
you and getting them to follow along
because you found some new cool way of
doing that thing they already agree with
i'm not sure how many specialist minds
i've changed there may have been a few
but mostly i've built my audience by
attracting the attention of people who
were already generalists or wanted to be
think of political talk shows they're
not necessarily persuasive to the other
side who on the right was ever brought
to the left by watching the view and who
on the left was ever brought to the
right by listening to rush limbaugh but
they're attractive to people who already
assumed that position it's only because
those talk shows are so assertive and
bold that people tune in and are
persuaded by them
either people pay attention and they
agree or people pay attention and they
can't stand a single word of what
they're hearing this is called the
howard stern effect you either love him
or you hate him but almost nobody is
indifferent about him
to help with your persuasion here's a
two-step networking and persuasion plan
step one reach out and introduce
yourself to at least one new person
every day try to form those connections
social media is really helpful for this
step two reach out and ask how you can
help someone already in your network
better yet just do something to help
them this will build reciprocity a very
powerful persuasion technique
ideas
share something with your connections
online comment meaningfully on their
work or send them something you think
they'd enjoy reading even better
introduce them to someone they might
benefit from
here's some additional recommended
reading how to talk to anyone 92 little
tricks for big success in relationships
by leo
loundez at this point i'd like to add a
measure of subtlety to this approach
although i've used examples like donald
trump and howard stern i don't want you
to think being polemic is the same as
being persuasive these are merely
illustrations to bring out a particular
element of persuasion which is
polarization you can be persuasive
without being polemic without causing
people to want to twist your bratty
little nose off but i'm not sure how
persuasive you can be without being
polarizing and that's what i'm trying to
get at to be polarizing is to make
people choose one way or another it's
about marking your territory and saying
here's what i believe and i want to be
as clear as i can about it you don't
need to be rude or offensive to be
polarizing but you do need to be upfront
about where you stand people don't need
to hate you but some will strongly
disagree with you or see your way your
style your product or service as simply
not for them and that's fine because the
more people you push away the more you
attract from the other side the problem
is that people are afraid of pushing
away they're afraid of not being liked
by someone and the trade-off is that
they wind up being ignored by everyone
there's a saying in marketing that if
you're not upsetting at least one person
with every advertisement you write then
you're not really marketing i think this
is true for everything if you're not
upsetting at least one person every day
by taking a stand on something voicing
your opinion or being clear about who
you are then you're not really living
think of the apostles those guys really
knew how to piss people off since many
were put to death because they just
wouldn't shut up about that jesus guy
and now look people remember them even
though they weren't all that well liked
at the time talk about polarizing they
weren't polemic or rude they just said
everybody else was wrong about well
pretty much everything and that was
enough
you can tell people they're wrong and i
think you should but only if you've
reasoned out your point of view
once you've got your life figured out
your religion your politics your great
good service to the world talk about it
you'll pull some people in and push
others away but i promise you this
you'll certainly be persuasive
boldness is a lost attribute in today's
society people are so afraid to speak up
about things even just a mild act of
courage goes a long way toward getting
attention that's what persuasion is it's
having the courage to speak candidly
about something people already think is
true
good writing is the same way and that's
why good writing is persuasive people
want to be happy that's the first thing
to understand
any action people take will be aimed at
happiness there are no exceptions to
this
but different people believe different
things will make them happy which is why
we can have valuable exchanges in which
both parties emerge better than before
thus if you want to be persuasive your
job is to find the people who think the
thing you offer is what brings happiness
whether that's a diet plan a skateboard
or a political ideology
persuasion i repeat is not about
flipping a person's opinion it's about
confirming it i hope you weren't looking
for any psychological tricks or cliches
you could use to close a deal on a used
car sale because that isn't what
persuasion is about persuasion is
finding points of common interest and
connecting over them
it's having the audacity to speak up
that's why persuasion marketing sales
whatever you want to call it is
inherently magnetic the more it pulls
some people in the more strongly it
repels others you may ask how do you
even practice this well you practice it
by again getting into arguments and
writing advertisements and sharing your
beliefs with people also by networking
by reaching out by being friendly and
offering help
i'd like us to turn our attention to
those last few points
most people suck at networking they suck
at reaching out and making friends this
is absolutely a skill and it is one you
need to practice
let's talk for just another minute about
persuasion through argument
remember an argument isn't about
exploding your emotions it's about
giving someone reasons to believe in a
particular point of view the purpose of
the argument might not be to convince
the person you're arguing against but to
impress whoever's in the audience let's
face it almost every argument these days
is a public event because almost every
argument is happening online
so if you're debating on a forum with
some person who's adamantly against
everything you do and represent i doubt
you're going to make much progress with
them
you never know who's watching the
engagement though even if they're not
engaging themselves
again when i was just getting started
with my business i would incite
arguments on internet fitness forums
when i say arguments i don't mean i went
into every thread and told everybody how
wrong i thought they were don't be that
person that person is annoying and rude
rather i would try to be helpful by
being clear i would say what i think a
person should do to reach a particular
goal and i would explain why obviously
because it was the internet after all
people would sometimes disagree with me
then i would have to argue with them
because you just don't let somebody
disagree with you again this is the
internet you're allowed to defend
yourself and you should especially if
you have good reasons for what you
believe but it should be done
respectfully
this is where one of your fundamental
skills logic can form the foundation of
another fundamental skill persuasion
remember my definition of argument which
is no more than giving people reasons to
believe in a certain point of view and
when i say you should start arguments i
mean you should try to be helpful by
giving your perspective on something on
social media in an advertisement
throughout the pages of a book because
that my little parakeet is the secret to
persuasion meeting people where they are
and trying not to change their beliefs
but rather to enhance their beliefs i
don't think i ever sold somebody on a
kettlebell program who wasn't already
into kettlebells my business was built
on people already using kettlebells who
wanted a cooler better plan for doing so
now it's one thing to stand up for what
you believe and it's quite another to
turn those beliefs into helpful vehicles
combine the two and your powers of
persuasion really blossom because when
you confirm a bias like i love for
kettlebells and then say how that bias
can further a person in some meaningful
productive way you'll probably have that
person begging to do business with you
maybe you're not even in business maybe
you just write books and want people to
talk about your stories well the same
thing being persuasive means appealing
to people like yourself people with
similar beliefs and ideas and views of
the world and offering them a special
experience novels can certainly do that
so can music
not to overuse my example that's pretty
much what i've done with generalism i've
told people it's okay if you're not the
best in the world and hey don't worry if
you're not because with the right
approach it's actually better if you're
not so people who are like me that is
not the best at anything we'll want to
hear more i'm not trying to persuade
specialists i'm only trying to get the
attention of people who already believe
in the position i'm promoting even if
they've never thought about it in the
same way i have
i'm helping people who are already hot
on the idea that they don't want or need
to be the best in the world i'm only
trying to show how the idea can be
developed that is persuasion
faith
you might be wondering why in the world
i would say faith is a skill and of all
things a foundational skill
well i think for a lot of people faith
doesn't come as naturally as it does to
others it's something you have to
practice because if existence can do
anything it can make you jaded it can
make you angry and upset and cause you
to call into question the point of being
here there's a lot of go ahead call what
it is [ __ ] that goes on in our lives
a lot of stuff that none of us
particularly like or can make sense of
for example deer ticks
also the nuclear arms race polio and
smog all these are seriously awful
situations and sometimes such things
make you wonder whether this is all just
one big put up job it's no wonder
nihilism is growing i spent a few years
in the department myself it was
certainly an experience
so yes i would say faith is a skill and
i think it's a necessary one
i think people sometimes equate faith
with credulity oh you just believe
things without evidence but that isn't
what faith is at least that isn't what
faith should be this is why i like saint
thomas aquinas with his preambles to
faith or what he would call philosophy
essentially he says here are the reasons
we have for believing the world isn't
just some random pitiless accident and
why we can trust in god's plan now let's
figure out what to do about it aquinas's
whole point though was to show that
faith was meant not to be infrarational
but rather supra-rational that is on the
far not near side of reason faith in
other words is simply trusting in that
which you have good reason to believe
many subsequent philosophers agreed this
was a turning point for me because for
most of my life i was anything but a
person of faith i was indeed a person of
science of facts and of reason
faith just seemed like unnecessary
woo-woo
if it couldn't be measured empirically
then what was the point or so i thought
then one day i got into an argument with
a religious person as i called people of
belief at the time and straight away we
quarreled over the existence of god i
accused him of believing in things with
no evidence and he responded by asking
what sort of evidence are required to
change my mind i said something
scientific would be nice don't you think
he replied that i simply had made a
category mistake and that no clear
thinking religious person sees god as
just another entity within the universe
some big bearded warlock in the sky
twirling his beard or twisting his ring
so to expect to detect him empirically
is to have a fundamental
misunderstanding about who god is to be
arguing against something that god is
almost certainly not instead of god is
anything he is the ultimate soul reality
timeless spaceless possessed of
intellect and will and so on an
extremely simple but extremely powerful
mind in other words god in principle is
not some thing to be found under a
microscope and there went my spaghetti
monster argument before i could even
present it he then trotted out a series
of logical arguments for the existence
of god that i had never heard before
arguments that were altogether
convincing arguments that i didn't even
know existed now i don't recall how
particularly convincing i found them at
the time but they did cause me to see
there was another side of the story one
i had somehow successfully avoided maybe
because i just never wanted to believe
in something like god
long story short i studied the other
side and after many years of doing so
reached the conclusion that there was in
fact good reason for believing in
something greater than myself that's
where faith comes in we can't prove the
transcendent whatever that may be at
least not scientifically because the
transcendent is by definition beyond the
purview of science but we can at least
make it reasonably acceptable and likely
or as philosophers like to put it more
plausibly true than not and that's all a
good argument is for all this of course
is a return to logic it's important once
again to note that faith is not below
reason but rather above it again faith
is on the far not near side of logic and
that's why it's a skill anything less is
credulity maybe even gullibility
in trying to figure out what faith is
i've decided it can be nothing more and
certainly nothing less than trusting in
that which you have good reason to
believe but you still have to take that
wee bit of a leap you still have to
trust in that which you have good reason
to believe it's like being married i
can't verify that my wife loves me at
least not empirically and to even
suggest conducting such an experiment
would cause me a considerable amount of
grief but i have good reason to believe
that she does in fact love me i'm
trusting in that which i have good
reason to believe
there is one problem with having faith
that i forgot to mention and that
problem is this as soon as you believe
in something greater than yourself you
must accept there's a reason for being
here that transcends your selfish little
ego that means it can no longer be just
about you you you all the time it now
must be about something else and
something more life probably isn't about
how much money you can make or how
famous you get or how many awards you
acquire
faith takes not only practice to have
but practice to live out since true
faith true belief means turning yourself
over to some greater plan becoming an
instrument if you will of divine
intercession
while i was writing this book there came
a point when i was extremely annoyed
resistance was high deadlines were tight
patience was short so i was a bit snippy
with people and not quite as polite as i
should have been i decided to take a
break that day to visit a local church
to see if i could pray it out a practice
i wasn't particularly sold on at the
time on my way to the church i
nonetheless asked god if he wouldn't
mind sending a spiritual pick-me-up i
requested something nice something
cheerful like the sighting of a dove say
i told god things were a little
stressful right now so if he could work
this one small favor for me well that
would be nice and how did god respond to
this i'll tell you by putting a kid with
cancer in the very front pew
now before my i guess you could call it
conversion to faith i struggled as so
many do with the problem of evil why i
would always wonder if there was a
loving god would he allow such horrible
things to happen in the world
particularly things like childhood
cancer which i think we might all agree
is at the very top of the list of things
that suck and make absolutely no sense
eventually i concluded there is at least
no logical contradiction between the two
that is so long as god may have morally
sufficient reasons beyond our grasp for
allowing such atrocities to occur then
such atrocities are not in conflict with
god's existence saint thomas aquinas
taught me that solving a problem
logically is not the same as solving a
problem emotionally however that day i
came a great deal closer to solving that
problem emotionally
as i walked into the church we were
handed a copy of a song we would be
singing to ben this little light of mine
throughout the service various groups of
people came to offer prayers and support
for this young boy and his family the
church was packed with people of all
ages and types each giving whatever they
could some flowers other legos and all
of us a lot of love the priest
eventually presented his homily he told
everybody in the congregation that ben's
presence was indeed a miracle in the
sense that one particular catastrophic
illness had given so many people the
opportunity to show just how much they
love one another and offer such profound
kindness to a family most of them have
never met
i just so happened to agree and began to
see a point in something i might
otherwise have written off as utterly
barbaric and gross i began to see how
suffering in some ways might very well
be the necessary means for us to build
character traits it would be impossible
in a world free of calamity and sin
this made sense to me a little bit i
then began to think if heaven is real if
we were free agents then certain
incentives ought to be provided for us
to become the kinds of people others
wouldn't mind spending an eternity with
without sickness there could be no
caring for the sick no compassion
without wrongdoing there can be no
justice or mercy but still childhood
cancer do we really need that
maybe in fact we do
maybe it's because we get so darn lost
in the noise as flannery o'connor once
proposed that god needs to shout maybe i
don't know more personal however was the
sense of perspective this experience had
given me
who was i to worry about missing a book
deadline god forbid while this family
and their boy were grappling with
arguably the most impossible struggle of
all immediately my ego was vanquished my
petty problems dissolved and i began to
pray i walked out of church a delivered
man and resolved to remain a delivered
man for at least the next several hours
but at that moment i became solidly
convinced of one thing god answers our
prayers he might not always give us what
we asked for but if we're receptive to
subtle or in some cases not so subtle
hints
we'll find he is always willing to give
us what we need and then some
okay great how does all this play into
becoming better at almost everything
i'll tell you faith is the ultimate and
perhaps only way of orienting yourself
toward happiness
it's what drives your efforts and goals
in a direction that actually will
fulfill you and actually could make a
difference in the world look i'm a
believer in capitalism if that hasn't
already come across but if it's being
conducted
by people of good conscience all the
better because then we wouldn't need the
stupid government to keep interfering
with things which almost always has the
effect of making the problem worse than
it was to begin with what's that harry
brown quote the one about government
being the only entity that could ever
make you feel grateful for handing you a
crutch after breaking your leg i like
harry brown he knew things
just imagine if all people were rooted
in a sense of higher purpose we probably
wouldn't have much if any need for the
epa or the irs or international trade
agreements people would stop doing
things just because they were profitable
and start doing things more because they
were good obviously i'm fantasizing
utopia is not of this world people would
still have to do hard and dirty jobs to
pay their bills and people were by no
means angels
but you can't tell me things wouldn't at
least significantly improve if everybody
were rooted in a sense of something
greater something beyond themselves
now i'm not saying without faith you
can't be a good or moral person i'm not
saying that at all i'm just saying if
your worldview is one of ultimate
meaninglessness then you don't have much
of a reason to be that's what nietzsche
taught me i like nietzsche he also knew
things at least some things i think he
was wrong on that most fundamental
premise of reality but darn if he wasn't
consistent all the way to his conclusion
that's one big reason we need to
practice and notice i didn't say have
faith not the i go to church on sundays
or i read a spiritual book once kind of
faith but a deep abiding love of
humanity and god faith is the orienting
mechanism as i said it's what can drive
you and give you a why so enormous and
unshakable and profound you're not
working out just because you want a set
of abs or learning guitar just so you
can get with groupies no you're doing
things for reasons so much more
meaningful than that you're building a
skill stack so you can change the world
even save it
and serve some greater purpose in life
having a why having faith is what will
keep your butt in the chair or get your
butt to the gym you've got to offer it
up
now take it a step further faith compels
not only trust but virtue
in other words it's not just about what
you believe but also about the kind of
person you become because of that belief
this again is very aristotelian
aristotle argued that the point of
knowing and making and doing good things
was at least in part to build positive
character traits
you do good things because doing is
becoming therefore morality is about not
only the acts you perform but the sort
of person you're shaped into because of
them here again is where faith can
either help or hurt depending on how
well you understand it you want to do
the right things but you also want to do
them for the right reasons because good
acts without good intentions don't make
a better person do they you've got to
want to do the thing you're supposed to
do if you get what i mean
for me that was always the hardest part
i was charitable before i had faith i
just didn't particularly want to be
mostly my generosity was driven by my
desire to buy myself a good night's
sleep now it's driven by love mostly i
had to work at that and i'm still doing
so it's part of my spiritual practice
we can argue that at the end of your
life faith is the only skill that's
going to matter ninja skills writing
skills your ability as a salesperson
none of that is coming with you and
neither is your beanie baby collection
your bank account or that cayman gt4
what you will be remembered for is the
person you were and how you affected
others this point was made painfully
obvious to me when my grandfather passed
he was a man i never considered to be
the epitome of success when i was
growing up he had a lower middle class
job and lived in an upper lower class
neighborhood he never seemed to aspire
to anything but that's only because i
had the wrong view of aspiration my
grandfather aspired to everything
because he aspired to love people and be
a man of faith and he accomplished both
he was the one who always held me on his
shoulder as a crying baby came to all my
sporting events however insignificant
volunteered constantly at charity events
and never missed a sunday sermon
his was the most crowded funeral i ever
saw people lined up around the building
like at a midnight premiere for a summer
blockbuster and that's when i realized
he had a skill that was fundamental and
essential and utterly lacking in my own
life if i had died that day i doubt if
even most of my own family would have
shown up for me the line would have been
like one at a matinee of a movie that's
been out for three months
my grandfather taught me that faith was
not just believing but also trying
really hard to make good on those
beliefs no matter how many times you
fail or don't live up to your own
expectations we're all going to fail and
to some extent we're all going to suck
at having faith especially at first but
that's what makes it a skill repetition
and resistance integration over
isolation just start with small acts of
goodness and giving bring water to the
thirsty and food to the hungry and offer
somebody who looks downtrodden an
unexpected compliment meditate and pray
at home or in church and then bring your
faith out into the world
then take on more challenges maybe work
a mission trip in there somewhere or
here's a challenging one tithe let me
tell you tithing is tough you have all
these plans for the money you're making
vacations retirement clothes whatever
and then you go and just give it away
don't tell me that's an easy thing to do
maybe for some people it is but
certainly it wasn't for me don't tell me
faith isn't a skill
yes make gobs of money doing good and
then give gobs of money away to an even
greater good but don't stop there and
don't be afraid to get your hands dirty
go out and do the good acts yourself
prep the meals visit the poor watch the
feet of some very sick person if you
tell me these things are hard i'll tell
you i know
honestly i'm not trying to be pushy
about religion which reminds me a friend
of mine goes to a church whose motto is
friendly but not cultish i like that i
think it makes sense
that's another person who knows this
whatever religion you are or whatever
religion you aren't faith should be
attractive because it's beautiful
because of the good things it gets
people to do and because of how it
brings people together
you don't believe in god because you
want eternal fire insurance that's not
what faith is about you believe in god
because you love the world and want to
save it because you love him and
everything he's given you faith will
stop you from taking shortcuts faith
will give you the framework you need to
engage in fulfillment if you need a
practice plan start with this when you
meditate or pray in the morning you
don't need to make it just an exercise
in focus you can make it a spiritual
workout as well start there
here's a few quick ideas to build a
spiritual practice
first morning meditation spend five to
fifteen minutes in mindfulness
meditation use a guided app to get
started if you need the skill being
developed is focus and the benefit is
presence and awareness this will flow
into all the rest of your life be sure
to do it every day
second mid-afternoon affirmations and
prayers
whatever your religious orientation
prayer is a powerful and transformative
practice affirmations also tend to work
well to spend five to fifteen minutes on
prayer every day whether reciting
affirmations chanting mantras praying
the rosary or praying in whatever way
your religion suggests you feel
comfortable
i prefer to do this in the mid-afternoon
though i will sometimes stack this with
my morning meditation session prayer i
found can often be a steadying force to
lead into meditation there are no strict
rules here aside from that you should
try to stick with one prayer or form
initially in order to set up a pattern
for yourself
lastly evening journal sessions
finally spend five to ten minutes every
night reflecting upon your day in a
positive manner don't just record what
you did rather explain why you're
grateful for whatever happened
this simple exercise gets you in the
habit of seeing the good things in life
and seeing that life itself is good a
much needed habit in a society that
constantly slams us with bad news for
additional reading i recommend mere
christianity also by c.s lewis
chapter 6 skills you may be interested
in but may not need
this next step is easy start getting
good at the things you want to get good
at this is not so much a next step as it
is a simultaneous step there's no reason
to wait to develop your interests the
meta skills while foundational don't
have to come first it's better if they
come sooner than later but this is why
we have a practice method and short-term
specialization and all that so we can
get better at many things instead of
just one what are your interests what do
you want to get better at there are no
rules here really the only thing i would
suggest is this if you're going to get
good at something make it something you
want to get good at
that sounds like a truism and that's
because it's true
remember when we talked about discipline
and how the only way to develop
discipline is by practicing discipline
and the only way to practice discipline
without already having discipline is by
doing something you like well it's time
to find that's something you like
when i was growing up i went through a
long stretch of being a seriously bad
student i'd skipped class and refused to
do homework once i got in school
suspension for showing my underpants to
my german teacher some thought i was a
degenerate the truth is i wasn't so much
a degenerate as i was disinterested in
all the subjects i was supposed to learn
in school i didn't really care about
calculus i didn't really care about
german either looking back i wish i had
paid better attention to both because
now i see the value in these things well
maybe not german but french would be
nice
unfortunately nobody ever taught me that
math was a way of learning logic instead
math was just a way of learning math
which i thought was a skill with limited
value when it came to high level
branches such as calculus i would have
been interested in logic maybe it's easy
to say that now
mostly back then i was interested in
music
this is why even as a terrible student
i'd spend hours practicing guitar it
wasn't that i didn't have any motivation
it was just that my motivation chased a
separate set of interests than what was
being taught at school
this is what i want for you i want you
to develop whatever makes you most
excited yes we need some quote unquote
liberal arts and that's why we have
those foundational skills and that's why
i took so much time explaining why i
think they're important maybe you're
interested in those or maybe you're not
but over time i think you will be either
way let's get started with the things
you like
what do you like woodworking painting
gardening cooking training dogs you can
make a business out of just about
anything you can be good at
well let's return to music let's say
you're interested in drums or you know
what scratch that guitar drums are cool
but i know guitar so let's go with
guitar say you want to make music and
you want people to pay you to do it and
say you want to grow your hair out and
get it highlighted i think that would be
just fine
let's go back to a few of our principles
if you're starting a new skill the first
thing to do is to short term specialize
in it this goes for guitar and it goes
for anything that isn't guitar i would
say you should dedicate at least an hour
of practice a day to anything you're
short term specializing in that's a
reasonable start you could do more
depending on the skill and in some cases
you could do less there's not an exact
prescription for this you need to use
some judgment to decide how much
practice is necessary and how much is
too much or too little when in doubt ask
somebody who's figured it out hire a
coach in other words now let's consider
integration over isolation what kind of
guitar player do you want to be do you
want to be a rock player a jazz player a
country guitar player or maybe you want
to be a generalist with your guitar
playing certainly i wouldn't argue
against that still you'll have to pick a
place to start so let's say you want to
learn rock let's say that whenever you
hear metallica it sends a yellow streak
up your spine because if something can
get you going like that it's a skill
worth investing in you probably think
that it's cool and resonate with it
imagine all the things in your life that
do that
maybe it's reading a piece of writing or
watching a comedian or solving a math
problem i can't tell you what you might
be interested in i can only tell you how
to get better at that thing once you've
determined what it is
for me
there are now quite a number of things
that fill me with giddy excitement i'm
not actually a huge sports fan but i can
see why people get into it debating i
love boy do i get giddy when somebody
gives a great argument on stage
something i only started to appreciate
after i joined the debate team in middle
school
what else i get giddy over yo-yo tricks
sometimes so i'm not sure i get quite
giddy enough to want to dedicate my life
to learning them but still it's enough
to cause me to learn at least a little
bit i get giddy over philosophy and
science and certainly i get giddy over
growing businesses finally i get giddy
over god faith gets me triply giddy
these are my interests most of them
anyway now it's time to identify a few
of your own
you might not even know your interests
at first maybe you have a few fleeting
areas you're interested in a few
suspects in the lineup so to speak
but maybe you're not positive because
you've never spent time practicing them
that's the test because to the extent
you love something you won't mind
practicing it despite the endless
frustrations that are absolutely
destined to occur i remember watching a
clinic by one of my favorite guitarists
back in high school and at one point
someone from the audience asked him how
he found so much time to practice guitar
he said seeming almost confused because
i want to play the guitar
to him it wasn't a valid question of
course he found the time to practice the
guitar because he wanted to play the
guitar how simple i mean of course
if you want to do something you're going
to find the time to do it this isn't a
question about making time or scheduling
or anything like that this is a question
about what moves you this is a question
about what matters most in your life
now hopefully i've done a fair job
explaining what should matter most in
your life
in case it isn't clear i'm not exactly a
moral relativist aristotle taught us
that there is only one right way to live
and that one right way is living well a
truism perhaps but isn't it still true
aristotle also taught us that living
well means focusing ourselves around
certain interests developing virtue and
most important seeking the good aquinas
his successor in many ways defined
happiness even more specifically when he
said it involves in engaging in and
enjoying genuinely good activities and
doing so to the extent that both the
effects and intentions are morally good
or at least
neutral
so there are not too many restrictions
here if you follow these sages you can
align your interests to produce actual
real authentic happiness
in other words something isn't good just
because you desire it rather there are
things that are really good for you and
so those are the things you should
desire
aristotle said this
he is happy who lives in accordance with
complete virtue and is sufficiently
equipped with external goods not for
some chance periods but throughout a
complete life and aquinas wrote this
it is impossible for any created good to
constitute man's happiness for happiness
is that perfect good which entirely
satisfies one's desire otherwise it
would not be the ultimate end if
something yet remained to be desire
now the object of will i.e of a man's
desire is what is universally good just
as the object of the intellect is what
is universally true hence it is evident
that nothing can satisfy man's will
except what is universally good that is
to be found not in any creature but in
god alone what does this mean actually
it's simple it means that while we're
alive perfect happiness can't be
attained but certainly a large degree of
it can be and that would be through the
prudent accumulation of knowledge virtue
wealth and friendship
people hear that word wealth and they're
like you was aristotle some sort of fat
capitalist or something i don't think so
but he did recognize the importance of
having your material needs met
aristotle was basically saying that it's
hard to be happy when you're starving to
death
even went so far as to distinctly
declare that wealth should be possessed
as with most other material things in
moderation it should be deliberately
built but not to excess in other words
make a lot of money if you want but
don't do it only for yourself in fact
you should probably give most of it away
if that's the case that might sound
unappealing to a lot of people but think
of the kind of character it builds if
you profit for the sake of doing good
rather than for the sake of stockpiling
wealth i guess you could see this as a
metric of sorts a way of measuring
priority the person who makes a lot of
money but they gives most of it away is
doing things for reasons other than
making money which is doing things for a
better reason we'll get back to talking
about practicing your interest in a
second but this is important i can tell
you that aristotle is absolutely right
about this because there was a time in
my life when i had gotten pretty good at
making money and frankly i still am i
had a goal upon leaving college of
making a million dollars before i was 27
and i accomplished that goal and i had
the fast yellow porsche and ate at all
the nice fancy restaurants and
vacationed at all the ritziest goldenest
places and you know what i'm not going
to say i was miserable that certainly
was not the case but i wasn't
particularly happy either that is i
wasn't particularly fulfilled
rather it was a constant game of cat and
mouse in which i chase a goal an object
or something i wanted to do or buy and
then i'd reach that goal get that object
or do or buy that something i wanted and
i'd enjoy it for a while nibble on it
play with it or take pictures of it and
then that feeling would fizzle out it
was very schizophrenic now that i think
about it the problem was that i thought
happiness was found in having
accomplishments and a nice big number in
my bank account it turns out i was
mistaken happiness is not found that way
happiness is found in exactly what
aristotle says doing and knowing and
making good things according to
aristotle happiness is more of a
cumulative quality than and something
that can only be assessed at the end of
one's life
it's not like the sort of happiness of
having a happy childhood or being glad
one moment and angry the next it's more
happy in a sense of flourishing and
fulfillment eudaimonia is the word in
greek to describe this and that can only
happen over time and then aquinas would
say perfect our happiness we need to
come to know god maybe that means
getting hit by a bus or something to
figure that one out let's not rush that
part in the meantime we can simply pray
the reason i bring all this up again i
just want you to have the right
orientation when deciding on the things
you want to get better at i want you to
engage in them and enjoy them because
they are good things to enjoy and just
about anything could be a good thing to
enjoy when done for the benefit of
others and for the right reasons
i think we could even make a case for
cage fighting but certainly music and
writing and mathematics and biology and
really honestly just about anything
it's so important so very very important
to keep the overall goal in mind we're
moving toward happiness we stack skills
to not only create advantages but find
fulfillment okay end of sermon let's
move on
so integration over isolation say you
choose guitar and want to learn rock
well then start with a song either get
someone to teach it to you or pull up an
instructional video on the interweb and
take it bit by bit right away you'll run
into something you can't do that's
something maybe learning to hold the
pick the correct way so you isolate that
technique until you get it right but
don't rush skills take time to set in
and it's worth spending extra time on
the basics your brain works very much
like a crock pot in this way you plop in
all these ingredients by practicing them
and then at some point you just need to
set it and forget it come back the next
day and everything will have hopefully
blended
and as you get better you sometimes need
a longer cooking time
initial skills are sort of like cooking
lettuce you don't need all that much
time to take in all the beginner stuff
and ready it for use in a much larger
recipe
later you'll get onto roasting chalk the
higher level skills that take a lot more
time to soften and set in whether that's
sweep picking or doing a freestanding
handstand your patience will need to
increase as your practice time remains
steadfast and dedicated remember you're
always working towards some specific
goal even as you are practicing
techniques in isolation maybe that goal
is to perform smoke on the water in your
living room in front of your
grandparents or to do your first set of
five pull-ups but whatever the goal is
be sure you have one and be sure you're
working toward that goal in some
capacity at all times don't just
practice techniques to practice
techniques integration over isolation
practice the techniques you need to
learn in order to do the things you want
to do and practice them in a context
that is as close as possible to the
context in which they'll be performed
let's take the example of another skill
at this point writing say you want to be
a human writer and you want to write
jokes whether you want to do stand up
write stories and columns or perhaps be
a staff writer for a comedy show i think
that's great part of your practice then
will be reading and listening to all the
funniest people you can find
just like part of the practice for any
musician would be listening to the
musicians and instrumentalists they want
to be like after this you'll actually
need to sit down and write obviously if
you want to be a humor writer you'll
need to practice writing thoughts that
make people laugh grammar and syntax may
need to be isolated but this should
again be done in the direction of the
goal i think what you'll find with humor
writing is that sometimes you'll want to
intelligently break the rules of grammar
and syntax to achieve a certain effect
like writer ring lardner was so
exceptional at for example in his book
the young immigrants are you lost daddy
i asked tenderly shut up he explained
you might analyze that snippet to try
examine what made it funny part of it
certainly would be the element of
surprise nobody really explains shutting
up to someone do they as if this needs
to be explained and such is the problem
with attempting to dissect humor it dies
in the process but when coming from the
perspective of a kid it kind of makes
sense it gave you an idea though maybe
you want to try to write a short story
from the perspective of your childhood
and maybe you want to bring out the
absurdities of family road trips great i
think that's a surefire way to get a
laugh out of almost anybody who doesn't
have material they could use from family
road trips gone awry
if you want you could borrow some of
mine i've got quite a surplus
this is integration over isolation
you're practicing writing but you're
practicing specifically in the context
you want to get better at now if i were
doing this i'd want to highlight
something about how my mom would fall
asleep in the passenger seat while
driving out east and how half the time
she'd still have a cigarette in her
mouth what would happen next is that
cigarette would drop onto her lap and my
dad would scream goddammit judy and we'd
all become hysterical and the whole van
would start to rock and swerve my mom
would awake with a start and search
frantically for the lit cigarette and
attempt to flick it out the window the
only problem was that half the time the
window wasn't open so it would typically
bounce and burn itself out on the side
of one of the armrests this isn't much
of a story in this format but that's
okay the first operation of any writing
project is to just get something down
you can shape it into something more
exciting later start with a very rough
first draft
all creative efforts are done in
segments you write songs by coming up
with simple melodies and stories by
devising simple themes
the details the nuances the tone the
decoration of language all that can be
added in layers the key for any skill
whether you're practicing technique or
actively creating is to get started and
work toward the goal in mind
obviously repetition and resistance are
also tucked into this you can't
integrate or isolate if you're not
practicing a skill and increasing the
demands as you go perhaps you move from
learning to hold a pic to strumming a
chord or from writing 300 words to
writing 500 to a thousand just be sure
that however you're increasing
resistance it remains in line with the
goal don't make things harder without
making them relevant in other words i
used to do this with guitar a lot i'd
learn a number of high level techniques
that took immense amounts of time to
master like sweep picking but they just
weren't all that useful for the kinds of
music i wanted to play especially for
the kinds of music people want to listen
to i was falling into the snare of
specialization of wanting to be better
just to be better rather than wanting to
be better in order to be good
let's look at martial arts now anybody
here have an interest in fighting great
because maybe you had a rough childhood
or maybe you've got a lot of pent up
frustration
not saying martial arts is going to cure
that i can say it helped me find a
productive physical outlet
but what would the principles of
generalism look like when applied to
this
well pretty much the same start with the
end in mind is your goal to compete or
do you want to be more of a showman when
i first started taekwondo i wanted to
compete that meant i spent most of my
time practicing the strikes that were
most useful as part of the sport
particularly roundhouse kicks but
eventually i got deeper into the
aesthetic side of the martial art which
meant i could then spend more time on
some of the high flying acrobatics and
techniques moves that aren't especially
useful when fighting people but
certainly look cool
i remember my coach would have me drill
kicks for thousands of reps and
sometimes we'd have to break the kicks
down into steps that was isolation but
it was all toward integration as well we
never practiced a kick i wasn't going to
use soon the same with punches and forms
and self-defense a lot of times we had
to break things down on a granular level
i think this is something you have to do
with pretty much any skill but you
should always know why you're doing it
the reason for such slow technique
isolation is that the goal is eventual
seamless integration sometimes often
actually you need to pull things out of
context to get them to work in context
so you repeat and repeat repetition and
you get closer and closer resistance to
bringing that technique into its final
form whether that's a competition
performance or act of creation it
doesn't matter what the goal is the
process is ultimately the same
what about something that isn't
particularly artsy or fantastic i know
i've talked a lot about activities that
i'm personally interested in but there
are also a lot of things that i don't
get particularly excited about but maybe
you do for example forensic analysis
anybody here want to become a forensic
analyst no okay yep that's about what i
would expect
what about a marine biologist then
anybody got a thing for whales or tiger
sharks
sea stars maybe let's say that you do
because this is something i have no
interest or ability in but i assure you
the principles of generalism still apply
take the skill of dissection for example
i don't particularly know how relevant
this is to marine biology but i'm
guessing some marine biologists dissect
things and certainly dissection is a
skill
i know because in second grade i had to
cut open an octopus frankly it was
disgusting but i remember we started
with just a small procedure for practice
and then moved on to the final operation
we were isolating so we could integrate
i forget now what we were even trying to
discover but i remember distinctly that
there was progression to it there was a
goal and that goal was broken down into
small little bits for us to practice
obviously none of us conducted a clean
operation one kid just put the octopus
on his head and pretended it was sucking
his brains up this boy quickly became a
classroom hero
it would be insulting to any great
dissector to insinuate that a second
creator could master the skill in just
one lesson
i don't know enough about dissection to
say how long this skill takes to develop
but i know enough about skills in
general to say it can't be acquired
overnight the point is this it doesn't
matter what you're interested in the
only thing that matters is that you
figure out how to apply the principles
of generalism so you practice it in the
most efficient way toward the outcome
you want
and you do so while keeping the bigger
picture in mind in some capacity you
remain oriented toward happiness and
flourishing and helping others
finally as you build your interests on
top of the foundational skills we
covered earlier you'll develop a strong
and sturdy base from which to launch a
career or a business there is one last
remaining element however even if you
build those foundational meta skills to
prepare and direct yourself and even if
you get really really good at things
that interest you on top of that there
often remains a chasm that chasm is the
gap between taking your good to great
ability and combining it with all the
other skills you have
and then bringing it forward into the
world and preferably getting paid to do
so and it is to that particular topic
that we turn now
chapter 7 skills you may need but may
not be interested in
now you've gotten good at all these
different things and you want to do
something with everything you've learned
you want to bring your skills into the
world awesome great fantastic superb the
good news is you might not have all that
much work to do between making friends
being able to think straight and being
good at skills people are interested in
you'd be surprised at how things simply
start to align
people might want to pay you to teach
them something or they might want you to
perform or to do a service but things
may not always align so easily there may
be times when you need to reposition
yourself
and what you offer to make it attractive
to people
let's see if we can cover the entire
study of economics in just a few short
sentences because i think that will help
you see how you should position your
skills to the world
people are rational animals remember
that means they think about things and
make decisions for themselves
but what are they deciding about at
first it may seem like people make all
kinds of different choices but mostly
that's a mirage
people typically make only one decision
and that is based on whatever they think
will make them happiest
they're trying to be content and there's
pretty much no scenario we can think of
where people make choices they think
will lead to their unhappiness
even people who perform amazing acts of
self-sacrifice are doing so because
they've shaped their characters to such
an extent that those self-sacrificial
acts are what makes them happy this
would be an example of aligning your
interest to something that is really
good as opposed to aligning your
interest something that is not either
way you are interested in something
because you think that something will
make you happy but if aristotle was
right then certain things have a greater
propensity to produce happiness than
others and those are the things you
should desire
but all that is really for another book
but we don't need to analyze every
decision people make in order to arrive
at the obvious conclusion that they make
choices they think will make them happy
either now or later in fact even if
people are doing something they don't
particularly feel like doing now
like waking up early to go to work
that's only because they know that they
will be far less happy later if they
don't go to work and get fired
what have we covered so far point one
people are rational point two they make
decisions because they want to be happy
now sometimes people also make mistakes
just because humans are rational doesn't
mean they make all the right decisions
sometimes they make very wrong decisions
but that isn't what we mean by
rationality by rationality we simply
mean that people think about things and
weigh decisions but they may do this
imperfectly they may make a wrong choice
or they may not have the information
they need in order to make the correct
decision even if there is one but again
people make decisions and they use their
rationality to pursue what they think
will make them happy this is the most
fundamental principle of economics
purposeful behavior
people will do what they think is best
in order to get the things they want
whether they are right or not is another
question
a large part of this process means
trading things with other people in the
form of either buying or selling that's
another fundamental principle of
economics voluntary exchange a person
will buy or sell something only because
they believe they will be better off as
a result of the exchange
in other words people will buy or sell
something only when they believe they
are going to profit from it and by
profit we simply mean increase their
subjective level of happiness nobody
will ever buy anything and nobody will
ever sell anything if they think they'll
be less happy after doing so that is at
a loss you can't even imagine a
situation when that would be the case
unless of course the situation was
forced as in a robbery or taxes an
economy grows because different people
think different things will make them
happy people value different items and
services and to different extents so
they can make exchanges and both parties
can profit somebody who sells a car for
thirteen hundred dollars is happier with
the thirteen hundred dollars and the
person who buys the car for thirteen
hundred dollars is happier with the car
both parties have profited assuming the
exchange was voluntary we needn't worry
that everybody will want the same things
and fight over them because not
everybody wants the same things to the
same extent or at the same time this is
why the principle of voluntary exchange
is so powerful and productive it allows
people to increase their subjective
level of happiness by trading goods and
services freely with others whereby
everybody benefits at this point maybe
you're asking okay pat why does all this
matter to me it matters because it helps
us to understand why people buy things
and why they might be willing to pay us
here we are with these really cool sets
of skills but just because we have these
skills doesn't mean people are going to
pay us to use them we have to make a
value proposition we have to show people
how our skills can make them happier
maybe you're solving some problem
they're having or maybe you're helping
them grow in some way we don't need to
know exactly what that value proposition
is and to be fair it will vary wildly
from person to person and from skill to
skill we only need to know that in order
to get paid to do what we love we must
understand how what we love can make
other people happy and furthermore how
to convey that message most effectively
to them
you can't just say hey i know martial
arts and expect people to pay you for it
but maybe there's a parent whose kid
keeps getting beat up and they want to
teach them how to defend themselves so
maybe that's your value proposition you
teach anti-bullying
certainly people are willing to pay for
that
we know this because they do
that's actually the first step in
getting paid to do what you love look at
and be a student of markets study how
people are already spending money and
determine if and how that matches up to
skills you already have
look at the people who are most
successful doing something and try to
discern what skills they have that you
don't this is where we complete our
skill stack we identify the few
remaining missing skills that will
maximally convey our value to the world
skills that will cause people to want to
do business with us when i was starting
out in fitness i looked at entrepreneurs
who were doing really well online and a
lot of them weren't in any better shape
than i was so i knew it must have been
something other than having great abs or
a heavy deadlift that made them
successful again they were generalists
not specialists
eventually i found a lot of them were
good at things like advertising and
copywriting and all those other business
skills about which i knew nothing i did
have the foundation of being a writer
even if i wasn't an advertising writer
but the more i looked the more i saw how
important the skills of writing and
effective advertisement seemed to be i
decided to pick up a few books on
copywriting and learn how to write
compelling headlines and catchy blog
titles and whatnot and what did you know
my audience grew i also saw that people
more successful than me were good at
selling things they knew how to make
their messages ooze with so-called sex
appeal
they knew how to speak in such a way to
their audience that doing business with
them would in fact increase their
audience's personal happiness whether
they knew it or not they understood that
most fundamental law of economics they
knew about human action and they knew
how to attract it they knew how to make
and offer programs services or goods
that spoke directly to the problems
people looking for fitness solutions
wanted their messages were so targeted
so precise it's no wonder they were
successful i knew i needed to learn
about copywriting and how to sell things
i knew i needed to learn how to make my
value known because that's all selling
is it's positioning what you have in
such a way that people see it as an
answer to their problem
almost everybody has a problem that
somebody with a particular skill has the
power to solve the only problem for you
anyway is that most of them don't see it
that way your job is to make them see it
that way i was already good at writing a
fitness but i sucked at sales so this
became a need-based skill for me it
became something i needed to get better
at to make a living by doing what i
loved that's why i studied it and maybe
you'll need to do the same i'm not
saying selling is a fundamental skill i
think it's a need-based skill not every
successful person is also a phenomenal
sales person some people just create
stuff that people want so badly it
literally sells itself which tells you a
lot about the nature of sales though a
lot of successful people are indeed very
good sales people plus a lot of selling
is baked into that fundamental skill of
persuasion selling focuses more on
specifics like how to price goods or
services and how to position yourself in
a specific market or environment but all
those specifics are pointless without a
more fundamental understanding of
persuasion to begin with
selling to the extent it moves beyond
persuasion boils down to this
people pay only for the things they want
if you hope to be successful you need to
sell the things that people want it
doesn't matter how persuasive you are
otherwise how many people like you and
want to hang out with you or come to
your birthday party if you're not
selling something that solves a problem
for people ain't nobody gonna buy it the
best advice i can offer about selling
isn't to study high pressure sales
techniques
rather it is to focus your saleable
skill in a way that will make it of
interest to other people in other words
give the people what they want and are
asking for try to make something so
attractive that it sells itself now
generally that isn't going to happen
it'll make your sales job a heck of a
lot easier
in some cases people may want something
not because it's entirely necessary but
because it's tied to some sort of social
status for example the iphone whatever
version it is now
the fear of missing out is a major
motivator for a lot of people people
often want what almost everybody else
has even if that thing isn't needed for
a good or happy life
think first about what you love and how
you can use it to help people if you're
a writer what can you do to sell your
writing because let's be honest it might
be difficult to become famous from a
novel before anybody's ever heard of you
what if you taught writing courses or
wrote advertisements or something like
that that at least offers a service to
fulfill a demand and could provide the
income and exposure you need to launch
that novel you've been so desperately
scribbling
you have to think creatively just like
you do in your writing this is what
generalism is about and it's what can
help you break free sometimes you use
one skill or subset of a skill to
subsidize another i've used my more
sellable skills of fitness and writing
to subsidize my i'm not going to call it
use a career because it's not really a
career but let's say musical activity
i've been able to get a good amount of
attention for my music not because i
started as a musician and grew an
audience by playing around in some
grungy old bar bands but because i built
an audience from my stack of skills in
fitness and writing i've used my music
on a lot of my workout videos and over
time people started asking who the
artist of a song was i pretend not to be
too excited when i said it was me
same thing with the book you now hold in
your hands there's no way i would have
been able to make this a noteworthy
endeavor without first having
established myself in some more specific
capacity i needed fitness to make myself
known before i became the guy who talked
about generalism i guess the point i'm
making is that with your skill stack you
need to start by selling what people
want to buy not what you want them to
buy then over time as people come to
know you like you trust you and so on
you can shake the system up a bit at
that point they've become more invested
in you as a person at least hopefully
that's the case assuming you've done a
good job and delivered the goods i'll
give you another example a friend of
mine sells a lot of albums as a solo
guitarist and people are always asking
how he's been able to make a living from
that his secret was that he didn't start
by selling albums he started by having a
youtube channel that taught people how
to play the songs they wanted to learn
and then offered courses doing the exact
same thing because he provided people
with what they wanted guitar lessons in
some capacity they came to know and
enjoy him and his style and as soon as
that started to happen they began
purchasing and reviewing his albums and
talking about them
people on the outside thought he got
lucky he didn't get lucky he provided
value and eventually that value was
returned to him he was and is a
remarkable generalist very skilled in
online advertising and marketing all his
skills helped build his presence on
youtube and all his skills eventually
funneled back into doing the one thing
he wanted to do more than anything
create and sell his own music
but notice the compromise notice that he
wasn't content to just make it selling
music online music that was very good
music that probably almost nobody would
have ever discovered if he simply
decided to put it out there
rather he was willing to accept reality
and position his skill in the most
helpful way possible to build an
audience after he did this people
discovered his music because they had
already discovered him
and noticed the skill stack he was great
at guitar created online advertising and
pretty good but not great sorry bob on
camera
these few simple skills when combined
made this once poor and shabby guitarist
into a millionaire
again if there's a hidden secret to
being a generalist it's how you can
adapt it's how you can use the skill
stack to provide value in one area and
fulfill your life's purpose in another
the specialist doesn't have this option
the person who refuses to adapt and
insists on making a living by only
selling the music is a person who
typically requires a subsidized
lifestyle from their girlfriend
boyfriend or grandma
maybe this is because they're too much
of a purist too unwilling to lead with
value rather than their ego that's the
beauty of capitalism in some ways it'll
humble you right quick if you've got an
attitude like that if you want to get
what you want you must be willing to
give others what they want there is very
little room for ego so the secret to
discerning need-based skills if there is
one is to emulate look at people who
have what you want and are doing what
you want to do this might mean reading
biographies and autobiographies which i
very very much recommend that you do
there's no way to figure out what a
particular skill stack should look like
without knowing what you want to get out
of it and to know what you want to get
out of it you should look to those who
are doing the things you want to do just
remember to look at the right things
remember to emulate the people who are
worth emulating not those who are simply
rich and famous
if you do want to emulate people who are
rich and famous do so for reasons other
than their wealth and fame
i remember way back when i was starting
out in fitness reading articles from
somebody who i always thought was so
interesting especially for a person who
was in the workout profession i always
thought he made such good points and
arguments it wasn't until i met him
about a year later that i learned he was
a history major and he told me how much
that helped infuse his writings on
fitness with such interesting little
tidbits at that point i realized i
needed to start reading history more
people like hearing about the history of
things that's just one small example of
how what seems like an unrelated skill
gave this person a very unique
perspective on fitness it made him stand
out you can look at more popular
examples too
angus young is a good one since we're on
such an ac dc kick and i think what
makes him appealing is that he's not
just a solid guitarist but also such an
interesting showman people who know
angus know him for his schoolboy outfit
and on stage antics his guitar playing
almost comes second it's his duck walk
and schizophrenic convulsions on stage
that make him almost impossible to
ignore
that's the stuff that people leave an ac
dc concert talking about in fact he
often botches his guitar solos because
he's so wild and animated but you know
what who cares it's a skill stack it's
funny you can't take your eyes off of
him he doesn't need to be the best to be
the best another example is mark twain
whom i became absolutely enthralled with
after reading a connecticut yankee in
king arthur's court in high school
people know him as the great american
novelist thinking he was probably
something of a specialist but i would
strongly contest that assertion twain to
me was the epitome of a generalist he
didn't just read and write twain studied
philosophy and history and was arguably
one of america's first stand-up
comedians someone once remarked that
twain wasn't a writer who performed he
was a performer who wrote not only that
but he was trained to be a steamboat
pilot and a business person
he was quite smart when it came to
marketing and selling books he didn't
become popular by coincidence mind you
the man was practiced and learned in so
many respects
in fact he's one of the reasons i became
interested in more than just one thing
the more i studied twain the more i saw
just how inseparable all his variegated
skills were from his success
but how about somebody who isn't a
writer or a fitness person how about
someone like benjamin franklin now does
anybody need to be convinced that
benjamin franklin was a generalist was
there anything you can think of that
benjamin franklin didn't do he created
political cartoons invented the
lightning rod and bifocals was the first
postmaster general and was a prominent
to say the least politician
he was learned in matters ranging from
science and philosophy to diplomacy and
sales all of them somehow connected for
him and made him into the man he was
someone we all know about almost 230
years after he died in fact when you
think about most of the founding fathers
you find men who were all generalists
their skills were far-reaching and
diverse and on top of everything most of
them even knew how to duel it was like
golf to them
i don't want to limit the scope or
restrict the kinds of people i think you
should emulate i think you should
emulate whoever you want to with certain
caveats and then use the principles of
generalism to reverse engineer whatever
set of need-based skills you well need
now for those caveats just keep the
focus on the fundamentals above all
always orient your skill stack toward
the ultimate outcome of success even if
the people you're emulating never quite
reached that you can learn from those
who were successful in business but
failures at life emulate what made them
successful a business discard what made
them failures at life while success and
money and fame can all be good they can
also not be good which is more typically
the case this is why we start with the
end in mind of doing things because
they're good and because we want to do
them not because we want to fill our
bank accounts per se it starts with
enjoyment and wanting to help people and
know things people who teach and do good
things for the sake of helping people
will be rewarded with infinite chocolate
and no weight gain in heaven i'm not
sure of a lot but i'm pretty sure of
this
eternal rewards aside it's the happiness
the right type of action brings you in
this life that also makes it worth
pursuing
conclusion remember life is best with a
sense of perspective
your brain does it feel good yet is it
so full that achievement and abundance
are leaking out of your ears
do you feel much much smarter and able
to conquer the world and whatever has
held you back from accomplishing what
you want you know the secrets now and
you didn't need the knights templar to
unlock the holy grail it's probably
easier than you could have imagined the
key is generalism
learning a number of skills and stacking
them meta skills interest skills and
need-based skills
so i hand you this golden chalice okay
it's a book and the chalice appears to
be green not gold but well whatever as
you begin your journey now we start with
a practice plan we treat our schedule
like we would a day in school like we're
students again this time in the world
school system there are just different
subjects to learn which means we need to
set aside the time to practice them even
if we don't practice them all at the
same time or for the same amount of time
if you ask me i think this is tremendous
fun
i think you will find it to be
tremendous fun also especially once you
start to find enjoyment within the
process you will achieve concrete
outcomes
don't worry about whether this will
happen as they're inevitable with the
process when you practice writing things
get written when you practice martial
arts people get judo tossed if people
fail to produce outcomes it's because
they fail to adhere to process and they
fail to adhere to process because they
don't enjoy it they do it for the wrong
reasons i can already hear some
objections burbling how am i ever going
to find the time to do this i have a job
you know and kids and all these other
commitments man
but what did i say earlier this isn't a
matter of time it's a matter of priority
i can't help you find the time
i can only help you look within yourself
to see that your self-actualization
your nibana if you will is so important
that any excuse not to make the time is
simply invalid you will always fail to
make the time as long as you continue to
make that excuse it's like the guitarist
who raised his eyebrow in confusion when
somebody asked how he found the time to
practice as much as he did he found the
time to play the guitar because he
wanted to play the guitar it's not a
tautology so much as a truism
before we go on this is something you
need to answer for yourself do you want
to get better at things are you willing
to make a mess and get lost if the
answer is yes then it doesn't matter how
little or how much time you have people
get things done with full schedules and
busy careers and a lot of kids they get
up early and they stay up late and use
instant coffee when they need to
because they want to get better and they
want to do things now i can't get you to
see that being better and doing things
is important i can only tell you it's
important and hope that you see my point
i don't have to learn these lessons by
putting off life until you're 97 and
regretting everything
i don't want you to regret everything i
don't want you to regret anything i want
you to finish your life knowing you did
the best you could with what you had
because that's enough but anything less
isn't enough then you're not fulfilling
your nature you're not acting according
to reason you're not doing the things
that god put you on the planet to do
this of course to pursue our own human
flourishing would be your ontological
duty as for the fundamentals you should
start the day with meditation and
reflection and prayer you could also
exercise
then you should do whatever you're
specializing in devote your biggest and
most productive chunk of time to that
often this will be an interest skill but
not always sometimes you need to
specialize in the fundamentals or need
based skills especially at first not
every class in other words needs to be
the same length especially not since
you're essentially homeschooling
yourself classes should be whatever
length they need to be to maximize
efficiency and effectiveness of practice
sometimes shorter is better sometimes
longer is better but it should always be
the least you need because if you give
yourself too much time to do something
you might spend a lot of that time with
your hands in your pants do you think
aristotle would be happy to hear about
that i don't think so personally i think
aristotle would be very displeased guilt
is good but deadlines can also help keep
your hand out of your pants don't give
yourself any longer than you need to be
productive at the task at
hesitating to say hand
clearly it would be impossible to set a
specific time frame for how long you
should practice each skill but again
this is where you look to other people
for guidance see what the teachers say
this stuff really isn't all that hard to
figure out i assure you if you think
it's hard to figure out you're probably
just being lazy you're using lack of
information as an excuse for not getting
to work which brings me to another
important point information as an excuse
it seems that a lot of people believe
they aren't succeeding because they
don't have enough information some of
the time that's true a lot of the time
however they have more information than
they know what to do with i know this
almost as much as i know how to eat and
breathe since through all my years as a
fitness coach the most common complaint
from people was that they had so much
information that they didn't know where
to start
there's just too much information they
would tell me it's also terribly
confusing when i first got into fitness
i remember being so enthralled by the
sheer amount of information on the
internet i was so excited at the
prospect of getting in shape that i'd
spend hours a day reading articles and
watching videos to learn as much as i
could on the subject of exercise and
while i certainly learned a lot i also
absorb no shortage of pseudo-scientific
twaddle along the way i took in more
than i needed to get started and get
ahead and there even came a point when i
spent too much time reading and too
little time doing a lack of information
became an excuse for what was really a
lack of work ethic
i didn't need to know more i needed to
do more i needed to stop reading so many
damn fitness articles i see this a lot
people spend hours reading all the
countless articles on exercise and
nutrition and that's all well and fine
until they forget the fundamentally more
important aspect of self-improvement
actually practicing the thing they want
to get better at read all the articles
you want but at some point you're going
to have to squat if you want to get
stronger watch all the handstand
tutorial videos you can find but only
turning yourself upside down on a
regular basis will cause you to finally
master one
burn through every business book you can
get your greedy little hands on but
you're not going to make a dollar until
you actually attempt to sell something
i've come to appreciate the seemingly
obvious but often overlooked notion the
so-called low information diet approach
in which you willfully limit the amount
of time you spend acquiring information
about something hopefully forcing
yourself to spend more time implementing
the information you already have again
integration over isolation
i found this approach to be virtually
foolproof for calling yourself out when
you should be practicing but instead
think it's somehow an adequate
substitute to just read up more on the
thing you're neglecting to do and this
is true for nearly any skill by the way
for example i used to fall into this
trap constantly when learning the guitar
i put off practicing and act as if
watching guitar clinics online would
accomplish the same thing funny how even
though i learn things i never seem to
improve until i stop watching so many
damn guitar videos this is normally
where i'd sit a person down and say
listen my little iguana the problem
isn't that you don't have enough
information the problem is you don't
know how to take action on the
information you do have this is where we
go right back to that fundamental
principle of generalism integration over
isolation and go to that low information
diet for a while that's where we consume
just the minimum amount of data we need
to get to work and then do exactly that
and only when we feel we really and
truly need more information to move
ahead do we seek it out otherwise we
keep our information intentionally
limited
i think people like to hoard information
because it gives the illusion of
progress that may be the case if you're
studying history or something but it
certainly isn't the case with any skill
that requires perspiration for most
skills you want to put action above
information you want to do more doing
than reading none of this is to say i
have something against reading i read
quite a lot and that's because i write
quite a lot so reading is a part of that
practice
i'm also reading only the type of
material i'm attempting to write myself
integration over isolation i'm not
reading to acquire information just for
the sake of saying i know things i'd
rather people say i can do things
because of what i know not just that i
know things
yes some skills may require more initial
information than others but the goal
should always be to spend less time
seeking information and more time
putting it to work be a minimalist start
with the fundamentals and take action as
early as you can
ah yes to be a minimalist this brings us
to our final point
it seems to me that if there's anything
left to figure out it's how to bring it
all together i can't tell you exactly
how to do it since i can't know how long
or in what order or in what way you
should practice all the specific skills
you personally want to get better at but
i can give you a mindset to go along
with the approach i already presented
let's talk about minimalism minimalism
is doing the least you need to get from
a to b and not a follicle more that is a
minimalist is someone who finds
themselves at the crossroads of
effectiveness doing the right things on
the one hand and efficiency doing things
right on the other
i say this is a mindset or rather an
intention because it's impossible to
achieve perfect minimalism no person can
ever be perfectly effective and
perfectly efficient in the way they
practice but every person should at
least strive to be to be a minimalist
you set hard and pressing deadlines you
don't give yourself any more time than
you need and in some cases you give
yourself dramatically less for example i
would encourage you to imagine what you
would do that is how you would practice
if you only had an hour a day to develop
yourself as a generalist
what would you work to integrate how
would you structure your reps how would
you add resistance and more important
what would you leave out this exercise
even if it's only mental is utterly
useful because it forces you to pull the
weeds out of an otherwise cluttered
practice plan an hour a day is not a lot
of time how would you fill that hour
with what percentage of which efforts
and of which skills would you strength
train for 20 minutes play guitar for 10
write for 15 and meditate for five by
examining and planning this one hour
scenario you can make the most of any
set of skills obviously in the above
example were short-term specializing in
working out since that's getting the
most attention but this isn't to say you
should only practice for an hour a day
sometimes that may be the case but other
times i hope you'll practice for more
either way it's about applying pressure
to establish priority even if that
pressure is artificial
once you establish those priorities you
can then stretch them out figure out
what you do for one hour first then do
it for four
most of the time this perspective will
force you to work directly on the
project you want to finish if you want
to write a short story restricting your
practice time will force you to spend
most of your time writing that very
story rather than diagramming sentences
not that diagramming sentences can't be
helpful but is that really what you need
to be doing right now get your hand out
of your pants
or say you want to post a skateboard
video on youtube i don't know enough
about skateboarding to sound even
halfway intelligent about it but i'd
imagine if you only gave yourself an
hour a day to practice this would force
you to practice specifically just the
tricks and techniques you needed to nail
in the video and probably leave
everything else alone for now
how you fill your hour will vary wildly
because so much will depend on what
you're trying to achieve at that point
if my goal is to record music that hour
will look rather different than if my
goal is to learn music start with a
clear vision of the end restrict the
amount of time you give yourself to
arrive apply the principles of
generalism and get to work i can't say
that any of this is going to be easy
surely it won't be but i also can't
imagine you picked up this book because
you wanted things to be easy i imagine
you picked up this book because you want
to be better and better at a lot of
things being better doesn't mean having
it easy and why should any of us want to
have it easy nobody who's done anything
and achieved a status worthy of praise
has had it easy
so easiness smeasiness what kind of goal
is that
process and enjoyment of process are to
be the goal and things can be
challenging and we can still enjoy them
in fact we will enjoy them to the extent
they are not easy but meaningful there's
nothing meaningful about doing work just
to sit on the couch but when we start to
see our progress take hold when we start
to rediscover ourselves and reinvent who
we are and what we thought we could do
none of that is easy it is fulfilling
though
when we get better at things and we
combine those things to increase our
freedom and abilities of expression to
offer a little chunk of ourselves our
personality and our passions to help
people and improve the planet and to
make life just a little bit brighter and
more simple and fun again none of that
is easy but it is meaningful
i'll finish with this the greatest
tragedy in life would not be to live
only a short amount of time
or catch a horrendous disease that turns
you into an astonishing case of
disfigurement like joseph merrick who
you may know as the elephant man the
greatest tragedy in life would be to
live a very long period and catch no
horrendous disease but to miss the very
meaning of life itself which is to
develop virtue to orient yourself toward
creative expression and willing the good
of the other and to know and make and do
good things love may be a simpler way to
put it not snuggly love but hugging the
whole world kind of love that's when you
know you're getting better for the right
reasons that you're improving in ways
that are themselves improving your soul
you don't need every skill to be able to
do this but you at least need some
skills and the pursuit of skills under
the right intention is something i feel
is just indispensable
remember the reasons you got started or
wanted to get started think back to
those moments that first sparked your
will to self-actualization recall the
person who exposed you to goodness and
beauty and made you want it and
hopefully that person inspired you in
the same way eb white inspired me when i
read why he spent so many hours
developing his craft
all i hoped to say in my books all i
ever hope to say is that i love the
world
now as you make your way into the world
i want you to take this with you help
each other out don't forget to call your
mom hold the door and smile at strangers
drop some non-stale bagels off at the
food pantry learn as much as you can
about whatever interests you be a
solution maker not a problem starter
don't get caught up in too many
arguments online try not to judge chew
with your mouth closed show that you are
grateful for what you have by oh i don't
know leaving a five-star review for this
book on amazon maybe
believe in something greater than
yourself trust your gut unless you're a
cannibal learn one new thing every day
meditate stare at flowers pet dogs go
for walks in the rain wear footy pajamas
if you want and never say no to drinking
a glass of wine or tea on the back patio
while catching the sunset with someone
you love
appendix profiles in generalism
david bowie
for those who knew him as a child it
probably wasn't overly surprising to see
where david robert jones's ever
developing and robust skill set led him
to become one of the world's most
recognizable and influential musicians
of the 20th century even as a young boy
david jones better known as david bowie
impressed choir teachers headmasters and
schoolmates with his art and design
skills inclination toward a variety of
musical instruments and poise on stage
as the years went by bowie further
developed each of his skills adding
others to the mix including songwriting
and acting
stacking stagecraft writing design
acting and musicianship bowie created
his famous alter ego ziggy stardust he
acted in various productions from
theater to the big screen and wrote some
of those memorable songs of the 1970s
and 80s his diverse set of skills set
him apart as one of the most iconic
musicians and artists of his age and a
quintessential generalist
dory clark
dory clark didn't set out to become an
entrepreneur author speaker and
consultant with a diverse set of skills
and multiple but congruent revenue
streams instead she started off as a
student of theological studies and
philosophy moving on from that she
became a reporter covering the political
landscape her experience there led her
into becoming a spokeswoman for
presidential candidates then she ran a
cycling non-profit
she was also a documentary filmmaker
many of these initial career moves
didn't work out clark got laid off as a
journalist and her political candidates
lost their elections but she soon
learned that she could uniquely stack
the skills she had developed to create a
new opportunity for herself and that she
could make a profit by doing so clark's
experiences became fuel for her ideas on
how people can reinvent themselves
become entrepreneurs and get the most
out of their lives and livelihoods
without risking anything more than
necessary she mastered email and content
marketing and became a regular
contributor to esteemed business
publications such as the harvard
business review the books she has
written showcased the writing
communication and storytelling skills
she developed over the years her
networking and speaking skills led her
to public speaking and conference gigs
in which she discusses her unique vision
of reinvention and of capturing and
capitalizing on the entrepreneurial
spirit she provides something useful and
new and different to a marketplace
already teeming with marketing
consultants and without having taken any
business courses or getting an mba she
is an adjunct professor at duke
university's fuqua school of business
and has guests lectured at some of the
most prestigious business schools in the
united states
and as an author consultant marketer
professor and business coach clark has
combined essential and non-essential
skills in a unique stack
generalists rule the world says clark
terry crews the term linebacker might
conjure images of a robust and muscled
man a brute built like a wall with
immense physical prowess but perhaps not
much in the way of mental or creative
abilities
actor artist designer writer director
and retired nfl defensive end terry
crews defies that stereotype
cruz initially went to college to pursue
studies and art he was even a courtroom
sketch artist in flint michigan for a
spell
and even while playing for the nfl he
supplemented his football earnings by
producing portraits of teammates and nfl
licensed lithographs after retiring from
the nfl cruz went on to fulfill another
passion of his movies he co-wrote and
co-produced a film about the devastating
effects of drugs on young men in detroit
he admitted the movie was awful but it
was the start he needed
soon came and moved to los angeles and
then over the years roles and films and
tv shows cruz went on to write his
autobiography detailing his life as a
christian an addict and a man who
overcame his darkest demons
his skills stack surprisingly well on
top of one another his creative artistry
helps him in his hollywood career his
physical abilities have helped him in
some of his physically demanding acting
roles and his understanding of his own
addictions and falls contributes to the
sensitivity he uses to get into
character and allows him to put himself
in the shoes of the audience asking
himself what they would want to see and
then performing it terry crews is a
modern day journalist a man who found
and developed his skill set and stacked
it on top of his main passion acting to
become a household name
dorothy
scottish born dorothy dunnett didn't set
out to revolutionize historical fiction
writing but as her skill set would have
it she did
dunnit began her career in the public
relations field acting as a press
officer for various government bodies
midway through this career she began to
pursue something a little more creative
drawing on her studies at the edinburgh
college of art and the glasgow school of
art she often accepted commissions for
portrait painting in the midst of these
dual careers she met her husband sir
alistair dunnet and had two children
however it wasn't until her late
thirties that the idea of writing even
came to mind when she lamented that she
hadn't anything of interest to read her
husband suggested that she write
something
so she did
but before the writing came the research
into which dunnet dove with a vigor she
became a short-term specialist in the
ages in which her books were set going
so far as to develop a new historical
theory regarding the protagonist of
shakespeare's macbeth
but then it was on the writing the depth
of her characters and her understanding
of the historical time period in which
they dwelt earned on it international
praise
when not writing these historical
fiction tomes dunnet stretched her
creative writing muscle and wrote
lighthearted detective works
throughout her many years as a writer
and artist
donet also used business networking and
potential skills to advance scottish
culture and the arts serving the
national library of scotland and the
scottish national war memorial and the
edinburgh book festival
she was also an executive director of
scottish television and along with her
husband was integral in developing the
edinburgh festival the world's largest
arts festival
creative and personable sharp and savvy
dorothy dunnett was truly a generalist
dave freeze dave freeze estate lawyer
stand up comedian reporter photographer
author taekwondo black belt dedicated
family man world traveler and as steve
forbes editor-in-chief of forbes
magazine called him grand master of
communications and persuasion skills was
told as a child by his grandfather that
he was an unfocused dilettante
even at the young age of nine dave would
immerse himself fully in a study or
skill that fascinated him geology
photography anything and for months
focus on that one thing until he was
good to great at it then he'd move on to
the next skill the next study working
tirelessly to learn all he could or
rather as he got older all that he
needed to in order to make money from it
because as frieze says money is a
motivator so if somebody was willing to
pay him that must mean he was doing a
good to great job at whatever it was
they were paying him to do
as a young man a local newspaper paid
him to be a photographer he wasn't so
bad at writing so he offered to write
articles to complement the photos he
took as a reporter he learned invaluable
listening and interviewing skills and he
learned how to tell stories he was
adventurous traveling the world with his
college sweetheart turned wife and
learning languages at least passively he
started companies through hard work and
tenacity these skills stacked one on top
of the other so that wherever he won new
zealand as a rotary exchange student at
the age of 16 australia great britain
the university of pennsylvania law
school he was able to listen truly
listen to people engage with them and
connect with them they made him
successful enough as a stand-up comedian
now with his estate planning clients
these skills help him alleviate tension
during a process that is usually somber
and quite stressful he uses his
photography skills to create and design
images for his law firm's marketing
campaigns his writing and storytelling
skills translate to effective marketing
as frieze says to outsiders this life
looks chaotic and unfocused but to me
it's always been a rich tapestry of
skill sets that fit together and serve
me well indeed they do as they would for
any true expert generalist
dan john
these days dan john is what i like to
call a master generalist a person who
exemplifies generalism by successfully
combining seemingly incongruent skill
sets
dan grew up playing sports out on his
neighborhood streets in south san
francisco playing football for school
was the dream but a brush with discus
throwing helped steer him on another
path
sending this full bright scholar to the
weight room where he began lifting
weights and putting on muscle a
fortuitous move that shot him into the
all-american status in track and field
unsatisfied with life only as an athlete
john pursued studies in religion he
graduated college with a masters in
theology and has gone on to teach
religious studies to adults both
domestically and abroad
john is the american record holder for
the weight pentathlon and the inventor
of an exercise have you ever heard of
the goblet squat and a philosopher a
professor of theology and an author as
well
he's also fantastically personable the
type of father figure you'd want to have
a tumbler of whiskey with or invite to
speak at your wedding
john has successfully combined his
skills of writing with strength training
and athletics to coach and influence an
entire population of professional
athletes and amateur exercisers
his deep understanding of religion along
with his people skills critical thinking
abilities and downright common sense has
helped him create his own philosophy
both inside and outside the weight room
that has shaped his and countless others
lives including my own
hedy lamarr best known as a hollywood
bombshell of the 1930s and 40s hedy
lamarr wasn't merely a pretty face on
the big screen though lamar got an early
start stardom in europe in the early
1930s it wasn't until she fled the third
reich and came to america that her
acting career blossomed during this time
however she devoted herself to more than
just scripts and screenplays along with
composer george and thiel lamar invented
frequency hopping a way of avoiding
signal jamming by jumping around radio
frequencies this invention for which she
was awarded a patent
helped form the technologies responsible
for bluetooth gps and wi-fi
when lamar wasn't tinkering or acting in
films she was a dedicated charity
fundraiser film producer and writer she
relied on her various skills to push her
career forward scratch the inventive
itch and become a surprisingly adept
generalist of the 20th century
spencer nadolski dr spencer nadolsky is
a revolutionary voice in healthcare
focusing on lifestyle changes rather
than medications to improve his patients
health and doing so in a radical way in
a completely online clinic he is an
obesity doctor general practitioner
author marketer athlete and along with
myself insomnia sikdar the co-founder of
strong on dr spencer is the doc who
lives
growing up in small town michigan
spencer was drawn to athletics so
naturally when he enrolled in the
university of north carolina chapel hill
for exercise science and pre-med he also
went for sports such as heavyweight
wrestling and did pretty well during his
undergraduate tenure then it was off to
medical school and residency and beating
the love of his life jenna and while
learning more about nutrition and
keeping up with his own fitness and
health
he wound up on the path that most
doctors follow working in an office
where the number of patients he could
help was limited by the number of hours
in the workday but nadolski felt he
could do more and that his purpose in
life was to help more people than a
clinical setting would allow so he began
to branch out learning effective
marketing skills email and content
marketing in particular to build an
online presence across social platforms
he wrote a book called the fat loss
prescription based on the success he'd
help his patients achieve as an obesity
medicine doctor he launched a line of
supplements he speaks at countless
seminars and conferences each year
building his network and practicing his
networking skills
then in 2017 he took the leap and moved
his entire practice online offering
everything an in-person doctor could but
doing it completely online this radical
approach helps him do what he wants most
to help as many people as possible and
to spread the gospel of a healthy
lifestyle by stacking his medical
background with his athletic abilities
his creativity marketing writing and
networking skills and his business
acumen dr spencer nadolsky has taken his
medical practice beyond the clinic
reaching thousands of patients social
media followers and members of strong on
and teaching them to live the best
healthiest lives possible and along the
way he has become an exemplary
generalist
lou schuler whatever versatility lou
schuler has he'll admit he just stumbled
into it schuler a fitness journalist and
author often tells the story of how he
got interested in fitness growing up in
st louis missouri he really wanted to be
good at sports but was consistently the
slowest skinniest weakest and most
four-eyed kid who showed up to play
that's why he started working out when
he was 13. both he and his older brother
hit the weights together and neither of
them had any idea what they were doing
but they kept at it until they got a
little stronger and a little less slow
writing is another area where he
thrashed around until finding his niche
he wanted to write fiction and
screenplays but even as a teenager he
knew the odds were stacked against
making a living as a novelist or
screenwriter
and he had no desire to go to a big city
and starve or freeze to death while he
waited for his big break so he decided
to head to college and major in
journalism as luck would have it he went
to the university of missouri which has
one of the best journalism programs in
the country without paying out of state
tuition for 10 years after college
schuler bounced back and forth between
jobs at newspapers and magazines and
students where he focused on fiction and
screenwriting while waiting tables to
pay the bills by the time he got his
first job at a fitness magazine in 1992
he'd been working out consistently for
22 years and for more than a decade he'd
been writing fiction and non-fiction for
hours a day virtually every day so even
though he had written at most a half
dozen articles specific to health or
fitness he docked out hundreds about
everything else along with thousands of
pages of novels and screenplays
he'd even done some stand-up comedy
right after college and now with the
rest of the world getting more
interested in fitness and nutrition he
found himself in the right place at the
right time with the right mix of
technical skills creative energy and a
sense of humor
he still needed to develop expertise in
fitness and nutrition and that was a
struggle without a background in science
beyond high school classes in biology
and chemistry and knowing nothing about
statistics schuler dove into the science
behind the fitness and earning those
credentials made him bilingual
he was now fluent in english and geekish
the payoff he can interview a scientist
without sounding like an idiot and then
write an entertaining article that a
non-scientist can understand weaving a
story that reflects the creative
problem-solving skills of a fiction
writer
somnath sikhdar the first time somnath
sikhdar now a sixth degree taekwondo
black belt walked into a martial arts
facility he was six years old filled
with visions of ninjas based on the at
the time
newly released movie karate kid 2. of
course back then sam couldn't know that
he'd just become a student at the very
same facility he would 20 some years
later own
but there were a lot of years and a lot
of skills to develop in between throwing
his very first kick to becoming the
owner of a martial arts facility and an
entrepreneur publisher business
consultant and marketer
sam continued to attend taekwondo
classes becoming more and more
disciplined over the years in the months
leading up to a summer long vacation to
india he practiced extra each day so
that he wouldn't lose the skills he'd
already developed perhaps back then he
didn't realize he was developing the
skill that would be most crucial to his
entrepreneurial success later on in life
discipline
he earned his first degree junior black
belt at the age of nine then a second
and by the time he had gone off to
college he had already attained his
third don
with his family's encouragement sikdar
attended the university of pennsylvania
where he earned a bachelor's in
electrical engineering and minored in
systems science and economics during his
college tenure as well as afterward
sikdar coached competitive taekwondo
teams at the collegiate level he even
used his combative skills as an extra in
a martial arts film
but sikhtar's successes go beyond
martial arts he along with two other
former peewee taekwondo students bought
the dragon gym from their former teacher
master chai taigo
only in his twenties sikdar had to
switch gears from the methodical
perspective of engineering to its
creative perspective learning how to
effectively market his gym through email
and direct mail increase class
attendance and broaden the gym's
offerings he added kettlebell training
and muay thai classes as well as yoga
physical therapy and massage therapy but
the skills in process management that he
developed in college and the discipline
he developed throughout his formative
years served him well as he created and
shaped the systems necessary to run the
business and improve the dojang he grew
up in he published books on martial arts
and kettlebell training he markets fills
and hosts certifications and workshops
each year and advises both national and
local business masterminds
along with myself and dr spencer
nadolski sikdar is a co-founder of
strong on and dragon gym is now the
worldwide strong on headquarters
sikdar's experience in running a brick
and mortar martial arts business and
workout facility makes him invaluable as
a business coach and consultant to the
countless personal trainers and
kettlebell instructors whom we help
through our strong on franchise program
he is also the co-host of a weekly
online show in top forum with another of
our profile generalists dave freeze the
show teaches viewers how to develop a
diverse set of skills to optimize their
lives and livelihood
from a proclaimed weak small and shy
child to an electrical engineer 6th
degree taekwondo black belt and
entrepreneur sam sikdar embodies the
generalist a person who can effectively
blend and stack a variety of skills to
gain a competitive advantage
donald trump as the 45th president of
the united states donald j trump may be
the most polarizing of all our case
studies but love him or hate him he's a
great example of a generalist after
graduating from the university of
pennsylvania's wharton school donald
trump took over running the family real
estate business a position he held from
1971 until 2017.
while at the helm of the now named trump
organization he expanded the company's
role beyond the building and managing of
real estate properties such as golf
courses casinos and hotels and
diversified into hundreds of side
ventures
trump was heavily involved in various
sporting events from the defunct new
jersey generals football team to the
hosting of mike tyson's 1988 heavyweight
championship fight he even went on to be
tyson's financial advisor he also owned
stakes in the miss universe pageant and
ran the trump university real estate
training program
outside these business ventures trump
has co-authored several books and has
made cameo appearances in movies and tv
shows since the 1990s not including his
role as executive producer and host of
the wildly popular reality shows the
apprentice and the celebrity apprentice
which aired for 14 seasons and inspired
international spin-offs
then in 2016 donald trump announced his
presidential bid politics had been on
his radar since the late 1980s putting
him in yet another field entirely one
that called on all his past skill
development to catapult him to the
forefront of a packed presidential race
the running and creating of business
entities is trump's foremost skill when
the one he stacked all others on top of
however a lot goes into running a
business management skills financial
management skills
risk mitigation skills marketing skills
networking skills trump's ability to get
as far as he did in both the public eye
and the political landscape
speaks to his people and communication
skills man also knows how to entertain
or at least for better or worse how to
hold people's attention these wide
ranging yet congruent skills helped
trump create the success over the past
45 plus years
and all these skills culminated to help
him win the 2016 u.s presidential
election
mark twain
mark twain samuel langhorne clemons was
a humorist author performer lecturer
inventor publisher and entrepreneur and
he was the great american generalist
while his legacy now places him squarely
in the category of writer twain came
from a wide and varied background
without his breadth over depth approach
he would not have enjoyed the success he
did in life nor would he have become the
storied figure of history he is today
enamored with steamboats twain worked as
a steamboat pilot for three years until
the civil war forced him into other work
fascinated by science he befriended
nikola tesla and tinkered away in
tesla's laboratory twain obtained his
first of three patents on december 19
1871.
tempted by adventure he became secretary
to the nevada territory governor a
silver miner and an overseas newspaper
correspondent talented in performing he
took to the stage regaling audiences
with his adventures and delighting them
with his quirky sense of humor he became
the world's first stand-up comedian
performing around the world in 1895 to
pay off his debts money management
wasn't in his skill set
each and every one of his experiences
passions and jobs at one time or another
stacked on his primary skill writing
steamboats and river life featured
heavily in his most famous works the
adventures of tom sawyer and adventures
of huckleberry finn
science and technology were a focus in
his alternate history novel a
connecticut yankee in king arthur's
court and his travels were recounted and
much to the amusement of his readership
stretched and poked and prodded and
became hilarious and poignant
commentaries in roughing it and the
innocence abroad
he developed his skill set over a
lifetime surging in some areas
maintaining in others who create a
career and legacy that surpassed those
of any other american writer then and
now twain was the quintessential
generalist
[Music]
we hope you have enjoyed our
presentation of how to be better at
almost everything by pat flynn performed
by the author
performance copyright 2018 by brilliance
publishing inc all rights reserved
for further information concerning this
program or other brilliance audio titles
please call the following toll-free
number 1-800-222-3225
or visit our website at
www.brillianceaudio.com
no part of this recording may be played
for an audience or reproduced in any
form it may not be streamed downloaded
broadcast or copied without written
permission
address all inquiries to brilliance
audio po box 887 grand haven michigan
49417
[Music]
audible hopes you have enjoyed this
program
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you